3am and the facility is quiet office
workers and administrators roam the
Halls security officers stand at their
posts clad in advance tactical armor and
carrying standard issue M4 carbines
three Foundation employees sit at
flickering monitors watching a live feed
of footage from the containment cell of
the infamous scp-106 or as it's referred
to by all staff the old man no
Foundation Personnel are permitted to
travel within 60 feet of the cell for
security reasons and nobody is permitted
to physically interact with the anomaly
without the approval of two-thirds of o5
command the observer's eyes itch and
Sting from hours of unending blue light
exposure but they can't look away the
old man is Crafty he might have the
insatiable bloodlust of a hungry great
white shark but he's not mindless he's a
calculating Predator more sadistic than
the worst human serial killer and he's
always searching for the next
opportunity according to the foundation
records he's been active since at least
World War II and it's estimated that he
has hundreds if not thousands of victims
to his name and many of those made
simple but extremely foolish mistakes of
underestimating him after all it only
takes a few seconds of inattentiveness
and the briefest moment of distraction
to give him the window he needs to do
what you ask oh don't worry you'll find
out just like they did the old man has
his nickname for a reason most of the
time he really does look exactly like
that an old man or more specifically an
old man's decaying corpse his body
covered in Rotten Dark grayish black
flesh that looks like putrid meat though
the creature has been observed being
able to change shape the rod seems to
run too deep for the old man to ever
hide it Foundation employees that have
observed scp-106 for extended periods of
time have reported seeing it assume the
form of grinning decayed children and
women whose rotted flesh barely hangs on
their creaking bones just seeing the
images through a video feed is enough to
cause a lifetime of insomnia and other
sleeping issues still they have a job to
do and the cameras remain fixed on the
old man he's been completely motionless
for three months just sitting there like
a a Buddhist monk in deep meditation a
novice might see this period of
inactivity as a cause for celebration
but those with experience know that this
is merely the Calm before the storm
scp-106 can remain in a dormant state
for months at a time described by the
foundation scientist as a lulling state
it's believed that the Old Man simply
waiting for its captors to get soft make
a mistake or simply have a momentary
lapse in concentration which is all it
needs to make its move it had happened
so many times before and it was about to
happen again one of The Observers must
have felt an overwhelming wave of
anxiety as he saw the creature ever so
slightly twitch just a tiny quiver in
the shoulder muscles but that was enough
to tell the Observer that their day had
just taken a terrifying turn he grabbed
the emergency phone fixed to his desk
and practically screamed into the
receiver that 106 is moving that they
need a Tactical Team stat but it was
already too late he and the other two
observers stared into the monitors with
their mouths Agape as a gooey rust-like
substance began to pool around the
creature on the floor of its cell slowly
creature creaned its withered neck
around its face was fixed into a broad
yellow tooth lipless Grim its eyes had
the kind of dull flat malice of an
underwater Predator it looked directly
into the camera directly at them and
smiled The Observers knew this was bad
really really bad with what they could
have sworn was a little nod the old man
began sinking into the rusty puddle it
made on the ground beneath it until it
had disappeared entirely scp-106 is
capable of phasing through any solid
surface with ease making it one of the
hardest entities to reliably contain and
earning it a spot on the dreaded keter
class reserved for the anomalies that
are complete nightmares to keep locked
up through the years of costly research
and deadly trial and error the
foundation would later devise ways of at
least slowing the creature down it's
shown to have an aversion to lead highly
complex or random physical structures
and intense bright light none of these
cause harm to the creature as far as we
know literally nothing can but they'll
at least buy you some precious extra
seconds with which to at least least try
and Escape seconds the three observers
didn't have one of them grabbed an
emergency line again and barked into it
that they lost visual on the anomaly
just then The Observers heard a faint
crackling sound behind them and the
hissing of a chemical burn they turned
in horror to see a huge Rusty burn mark
expanding across the wall right next to
the door which was their only Escape
Route they backed as far away from the
door as they could as a rotten hand
began reaching out of the mass of
corrosive black sludge followed by the
grinning face of scp-106 ready to have
some fun meanwhile two heavily armed
security officers agents Goodwin and
Resnick came charging down the corridor
toward the observation rooms it become a
bleak slogan during scp-106 Escape
attempts that all you need to do is
follow the screams and that motto was
proven true that night because awful
things were happening to the observation
Personnel they were certainly screaming
about it of course even with the top of
the line firearms there was little they
could do to harm the rampaging old man
he seemed immune to all forms of
physical damage all they could hope to
do was keep the thing distracted until
the scientists and containment
Specialists finish the preparations to
lure him back into his containment cell
Goodwin surged forward while Resnick
covered his six vigilance was key as
unlike a standard human combatant
scp-106 could attack from literally any
angle including above or below physical
obstacles were irrelevant to him and no
cover was safe the hardened security
officers could see the burn mark on the
wall of the observation room as they
approached scp-106 was perpetually
coated in a thick black mucus with
powerful corrosive properties that left
any surfaces it touched permanently
marked Foundation scientists speculated
that this mucus served as a kind of
pre-digestive substance that tenderizes
meat and Bone alike but to what purpose
this serves as a mystery as the old man
has never been observed eating it's
postulated that the only purpose is
causing additional pain Goodwin in
Resnick knew to treat this hissing
sludge as a Potential Threat as the
corrosive properties would remain active
for as much as six hours before finally
fizzling out the two officers shared a
quiet nod before Goodwin breached the
observation room door with a hard kick
the two of them searched inside guns at
the ready in their time working at the
foundation they'd seen some truly
horrific sites from the mutilation of
d-class personnel typically death row
prison inmates brought in for use as SCP
guinea pigs to the violence and Mayhem
of a containment bridge but there was
nothing in their past that would ever
make the horrifying sight they saw in
the observation room that night feel
normal all three observers were dead
almost nothing remained of two of them
and the third while still intact no
longer looked human he looked like he'd
somehow been dead a hundred years in the
brief period that the old man had been
free his skin was gray and completely
dried out and its mouth was locked into
a Perpetual scream it was a massacre but
there was no sign of the old man Goodwin
grabbed his radio and whispered this is
Goodwin in observation room 6 requesting
immediate backup we have no idea where
this thing but his sentence was cut off
by a sudden scream from agent Resnick
SCP Foundation security officers are as
tough as Nails the best of the best you
might say recruited from the top
military organizations in the world so
hearing one of them scream in Fright is
a rare if not impossible occurrence but
even they were forced to yell out in
fear when they looked up to see the old
man standing on the ceiling grinning
down at them Resnick raised his M4 and
shot a three-round burst at Center Mass
scp-106 didn't care even under sustained
gunfire from the two security officers
it didn't glitch The Old Man simply
reached down and snatched agent Resnick
from the ground like it was picking an
apple from a tree the old man held
rasnick in one hand and pounded its
other rotten fist into the agent's body
breaking all of his bones Resnick
screamed for his partner to help him but
there was no time before Goodwin could
do anything scp-106 began receding back
into another slimy burn mark on the wall
only this time he was taking his
screaming victim with him agent Resnick
gave one more horrified screen before he
was pulled backward into the inky
Darkness leaving the room silent except
for the burning hiss of the corrosive
left behind you might think this would
be the end of it but no for poor agent
Resnick the worst was yet to come he was
being dragged into what the SCP
Foundation scientists refer to as the
old man's pocket Dimension a miniature
layer of reality within our own where
the malicious SCP is essentially a cool
all-powerful God according to witness
reports extracted from victims who were
taken to this little nightmare realm the
dimension resembles a series of twisting
endless corridors where the old man
stalks and torches had captured victims
to the breaking point manipulating space
and time to his own sadistic ends on
rare occasions the SCP will even release
its victims just for the joy of hunting
capturing and torturing them all over
again while agent Resnick was learning
the true meaning of Terror containment
Specialists were mobilizing in itself
preparing the one known tried and true
method of alluring the old man back
tempting it with the prospect of causing
even more suffering in order to do this
Foundation Personnel take one of the
aforementioned class personnel and begin
inducing extreme pain by breaking a
major bone or slicing a tendon every 20
minutes the victim's agonizing screams
are then played over the facility's
intercom acting as bait for the
pain-loving old man the screams echo
through the facilities otherwise silent
Halls as the mutilated corpse of agent
Resnick falls from a new Scorch mark on
the ceiling the old man can hear the
sounds of suffering ringing out through
the air around him and he can barely
contain his excitement over the prospect
of a new plaything the snapped femurs
the torn Achilles tendons it was all too
good to miss having had its Twisted fun
with the security officers and observers
scp-106 wandered back to its containment
cell where a new screaming victim
awaited the other security officers
containment Specialists and scientists
evacuated the area leaving the old man
alone with his prey while the
unfortunate class D was left to his fate
the rest of the staff commenced cleanup
procedures which mainly involve wiping
the brown and black mucus from the walls
it would probably be at least another
month before any anything like this
happened again and a new Personnel would
be transferred over to the facility to
replace the Fallen all in all just
another night at the SCP Foundation
there are some things human beings
aren't meant to know and it's the sworn
duty of the SCP Foundation to discover
and contain such information but
sometimes knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the foundation itself to its
very core one such Discovery occurred on
April 28 2016. that night
scp-2935 made itself known to the
foundation Personnel to this day the
exact nature of scp-2935 is a mystery
that even the foundation's brightest
Minds can't completely understand
everything we know about
scp-2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous Zone's
interior this is the story of those
Infamous Expeditions the nightmare began
around 5am when SCP Foundation site 81
in Bloomingdale Indiana intercepted a
distorted radio signal Communications
Personnel at the site trace this strange
signal back to to the unincorporated
area of Joppa Indiana near U.S
Interstate 70 as is foundation policy a
team of field agents were dispatched to
the location in order to determine what
they were dealing with however rather
than finding anything that could
logically produce such a signal they
instead discovered a long abandoned
Cemetery the most recent death on any of
the Tombstones was recorded as being
over a hundred years ago all the way
back in 1908 on further investigation
the foundation discovered an unmapped
Limestone Cave opening beneath the
cemetery and when they sent a drone into
the depths of the cave it appeared to
quickly exit out the other side of the
cave but something wasn't right the area
that the Drone was observing appeared
consistent with the landscape from which
it entered but now it looked somehow
grayer it lacked the color of life of
the place it just come from the grass
was dead there were no trees no shrubs
no animals or birds in the sky they
weren't looking at our world they were
looking at a strange reflection of our
world on the other side of the cave in
fact it wasn't a cave at all it was a
passageway between two Dimensions it was
scp-2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and to national
government one or more of our sites is
experiencing a communication breakdown
likely due to a containment breach of
unknown magnitude all citizens are
ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
April 20th 2016. until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
Source site 81 but not this site-81 the
SCP Foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site-81 commands to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the potential
threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force Epsilon 13 codenamed Manifest
Destiny to perform the first of three
manned missions Into the Heart of the
anomalous Zone the first exploratory
Mission into scp-2935 was codenamed
Gauntlet and consisted of a four-man
team fitted with full hazmat suits and
direct video and audio links to Mission
command the team was led by a field
operative known only as agent Juno his
subordinates were agents kale Devon and
Underwood their directive was to gather
samples and Survey the area positioned
directly around the insertion point
meaning the other cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of their
lives after a 15-minute Trek through the
cave manifests Destiny arrived in the
mirror Dimension where they were struck
by the Eerie Silence of a place that
seemed identical and yet so different
from their home Dimension the first
observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation trees
grass weeds everything it all dead on
orders from their superiors back in the
original Dimension that we'll refer to
from here on as Dimension Prime Manifest
Destiny headed deeper into the mirror
dimension of scp-2935 they travel two
kilometers without detecting a single
sign of plant or animal life not even
insects eventually They Came Upon a
farmhouse with two cars parked outside
with authorization from command Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed
inside agent kale confirmed that there
was still power flowing to the building
as the lighting appeared to work just
fine but They Came Upon A horrifying
Discovery in The house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
were seated at the table a fourth corpse
that of a male child was sprawled out on
the ground nearby as if the death of
what looked to be an entire family
wasn't awful enough the Manifest Destiny
team noticed a number of other alarming
details there were no signs of
decomposition on the bodies nor did
there appear to be any obvious cause of
death the Family's last meal was still
on the table chicken mashed potatoes and
green beans while the food looked cold
and stale there was no evidence of rot
or spoiling the team found an open
newspaper dated April 19 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full eight days before the
discovery in dimension Prime Decay would
already be very well underway by that
point yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that Manifest Destiny collects samples
of the food as well as Hair Skin and
fluids from the corpses for further
study small electronics like smartphones
were also taken from the bodies agent
Devin turned on the television in the
living room and found that while most
stations were now running test signals
the shopping channel was still live well
the feed was live at least both hosts
sat in front of the cameras dead but
perfectly preserved the date on the
screen read April 28 2016 suggesting
that the times of Dimension crime and
mirror Dimension were exactly the same
in fact everything seemed the same the
only difference between the two
Dimensions being that some kind of
mysterious apocalyptic event had
occurred in the last eight days in
scp-2935 smear Dimension but exactly
what had happened or how remained a
mystery when Manifest Destiny exited the
Farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them at this point the team returned to
the insertion point of scp-2935 but were
instructed to remain in the mirror
Dimension while additional units joined
them inside Manifest Destiny swelled the
16 members with the notable edition of
agent Roy as the new commanding field
officer the team split into two groups
of eight and agent Roy and his men
infiltrated the mirror Dimension site-81
while agent Juno's Detachment attempted
to access the basis off-site deep
storage servers this second expedition
was codenamed Overland and led the
foundation's field agents even deeper
into the terrifying mystery of scp-2935
accessing the site was easy for Roy's
Detachment it seemed there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious Extinction event
in the distance fires still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to
have just dropped out of the sky agent
Roy and his team like all SCP Foundation
Personnel were fitted with vitals
trackers and they assumed that the
distress signal that started this whole
thing could have been triggered by the
deaths of every member of the foundation
at Once In The Mirror Universe once
inside site 81 they realized that the
Assumption was probably right going door
to door in the administrative Wing they
found the perfectly preserved corpses of
everyone they knew to be stationed there
in dimension Prime people who were
without a doubt still alive in their
Universe samples from the corpses that
the foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in a
decomposition process had died with it
and scp-2935 death was total and
absolute across all types of life forms
as agent Roy's team ventured further
into the bowels of site-81 they made
another unsettling Discovery their own
corpses in roughly the same spots they'd
been inside Dimension Prime site 81 8
days prior some of the foundation's top
scientists including the esteemed Dr
bright were were also found dead inside
the facility in an attempt to see just
how far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched agent Roy's team decided to
inspect the containment cells where they
found that all the mirror universe's
scps including scp-2996 were dead in his
desperation to find some kind of
exception to the extinction event agent
Roy revealed a terrifying secret to the
rest of his team scp-682 The Immortal
misanthropic lizard and one of the
deadliest creatures known to the SCP
Foundation was contained at this very
facility right below them could it have
something to do with what was going on
here they descended into the containment
facility to discover an even more
unsettling truth scp-682 the unkillable
anomaly floated dead in its tank death
truly made no exceptions within scp-2935
agent Roy's team left the site in rendez
food with agent Juno's team to send
their research back to Dimension prime
using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another manned operation codenamed 19.
they had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3 A.M while
underground in scp-2935 site-81 the team
accidentally activated the bases on-site
nuclear weapon a Fail-Safe meant to be
detonated in the case of an emergency
Containment Breach due to the basis
Fail-Safe protocols every member of the
Manifest Destiny team was locked and
sealed inside site-81 they along with
everything else were incinerated in the
nuclear blast once again the Mirror
Universe inside of scp-2935 was lifeless
but that isn't where it ends when the
automated drones returned out of the
scp-2935 cave to the field operations in
dimension Prime they were in for their
own horrifying Discovery none of the
footage or information gathered from
scp-2935 illuminated how or why the
extinction event occurred everyone and
everything simply dropped dead at the
exact same moment nobody was aware
nobody was prepared death came suddenly
and silently and none were spared all
the foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the
agents from Manifest Destiny agent
Keller his final message was I don't
have any answers I don't think there are
any I'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us I'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site 81. it was a message from Keller
himself but not the Keller from Universe
Prime in this message Keller described
the foundation in the Mirror Universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did a few days
earlier from a cave in Joppa when he and
the others were dispatched inside they
discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar to the foundation command
but there was a key difference this
wasn't the mirror Dimension they'd just
been studying but a third entirely
different dimension in his haunting
final words mirror Dimension Keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror Dimension Keller believes this
was the Specter of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history had repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass from
Dimension to Dimension and our Dimension
was the next in line the deaths of
manifest destiny may have saved our
entire universe as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to
bring death itself back with them the
foundation decided in the end to follow
Keller's advice they sealed the entrance
to scp-2935 with concrete and now kept
it under constant watch since what Waits
behind the barrier is an entity even
they have no power to stop if it ever
got through after all it had killed them
all before or at least another version
of them what's one more dimension on the
pile why it may now just seem like a
simple slab of concrete under an
abandoned Cemetery this is why scp-2935
might be the most dangerous SCP of all
an SCP found Foundation researcher sits
at a table inside of a standard
containment cell these are often
dangerous places to be especially when
the SCP you're supposed to be studying
is one that you can't see the researcher
is taking notes unsure of exactly what
is going to happen next he can hear the
sounds of knives scraping behind of
Flesh sizzling and Searing from high
heat he braces himself as a burst of
heat hits the back of his head as if a
fireball has erupted an object floats
through the air and settles in front of
him on the table it's a plate of food
and it looks delicious it may surprise
you to learn that there is no rule that
the SCP Foundation must deal exclusively
with violent and vicious creatures not
every SCP held in containment shares the
same malevolence and contempt for
Humanity as scp-682 or the world-ending
threat posed by the likes of
scp-2317 some perhaps not many but some
are benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with
scp-5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this
quasi-humanoid meaning it appears to
have some vaguely human features is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly
checked by Foundation Personnel on a
bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with scp-5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything it encounters human or
otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen But
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism
which is when observed it will literally
cease to exist
some might choose to refer to this as a
Quantum lock however it is worth noting
that Trace is left by scp-5031 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by scp-5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when scp-5031's
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creature's
physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced at scp-5031 levitates about half
a meter above ground level Sports in
abnormally small necklace head atop an
elongated torso approximately 1.9 meters
long
with three sets of spindly lower arms
that Branch outwards using these arms
and its Loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes for the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kept in Huxtable
took over the role of hcl's supervisor
for
scp-5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit
Huxtable devised a series of tests to
introduce scp-5031 to various different
stimuli as a way to better understand
the creature and hopefully keep it
contained in a way that didn't seem to
cause so much suffering it's worth
remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes its mission to be cold not cruel
in performing their duties to protect
normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a shelter
the first of huxtable's tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging scp-5031 stress levels based on
how much it screened when compared to
normal
Huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
Forest deep Grotto and seaside Paradise
Ambience as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull however
the best of Mozart Enya kiss and Ben
Folds produce dramatically different
results decreasing scp-5031's apparent
stress following this test senior
researcher Huxtable compiled a playlist
featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress reducing effects of Music on
scp-5031 seemed to decrease
but keeping the playlist on shuffle
seemed to keep the creature consistently
calmer than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected when a softball was thrown into
the enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second volleyball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher Huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher Huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher Huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken's stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031 gently rolled a basketball
towards it but ceased any further
engagement after the chicken squawked
from being hit by the ball next to be
introduced into the enclosure was a
blindfolded d-class staff member who was
instructed to sit down and roll the
basketball towards
scp-5031 after doing so for several
minutes the creature began to approach
the d-class subject who was instructed
to remove their blindfold to Cease the
creature's existence and prevent any
potentially deadly incidents finally
researcher Huxtable had another class D
engage in a game of catch with scp-5031
while facing away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
Senior researcher Huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized LCD
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser One display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
Final Phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain in active
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher Huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
Huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received senior
researcher Huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
Dish pairings
later another class D
d-52125 was introduced to scp-5031's
enclosure to Aid in further testing
through
d-52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its Newfound friend
d-52125 researcher Huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and
d-52125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices using its letter blocks to
request more more garlic powder
interestingly the creature only created
artwork or music when d-52125 was
present but seemed to thoroughly enjoy
its experimentation with food when left
alone
following this development senior
researcher Huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031 providing the creature with
cooking utensils and using
d-52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown
how to prepare a variety of different
dishes from hamburgers and Tacos to
Mongolian beef steak clam chowder and
profiteroles in addition to a small
peanut allergy this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
Newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with d-52125 even
volunteering to be the first to taste
test 50 31's dishes it was shortly after
this test that scp-5031 spoke its very
first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was solved naturally senior
researcher Huxtable was very proud of
the progress the creature had made with
its development the final test almost
seemed to be what the creature was born
for over the course of two months
scp-5031 was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal which would then be
served to Foundation staff for
Thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only Rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
Gordon Ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck calm fee blazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped
generously with sweet cranberry compote
paired with a side of butternut squash
gnocchi and served on a bed of kales
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the Exquisite meal was a spice
cassava pie for dessert complimented
with the finest French vanilla ice cream
and a maple hazelnut syrup
an scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher Huxtable but
the entire Foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's tail Huxtable
reported that during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created
scp-5031 stress levels reduced entirely
new Kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world
instead scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and Flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow under the
proud watch of researcher Huxtable
ah here we go again it's time to return
to the acid-filled containment chamber
of
scp-682 more commonly known as the hard
to destroy reptile we've spoken about
him and the ways the SCP Foundation has
attempted to destroy him in a previous
video but as we said back then and we
really only scratched the surface of the
huge number of insane ways the
foundation has tried to wipe this cranky
lizard off the face of the Earth today
we're filling in some of the cracks and
taking a look at the secret teslogs
detailing the foundation's unsuccessful
quest to finally destroy
scp-682 some of these may surprise you
and if you're a real SCP expert you may
just recognize some familiar faces we
meet along the way esteemed Foundation
researcher Dr alto clef famed for a
somewhat unconventional personality
entered the test chamber to see if he
could intimidate the Beast to death this
resulted in a long staring contest
between Dr clef and 682 towards the end
of the competition Dr cleff began to
lose his nerve he tried to leave the
room only to find that the door was
locked causing him to swear loudly Dr
clef who always tries to fight find the
most direct solution to his problems
blew up the door with plastic explosives
and ran off the result test failed next
came
scp-662 a silver handbell that summons
The supernaturally Helpful Butler Mr
Deeds when Mr Deeds was summoned
Foundation researchers asked him if he
could kill
scp-682 Deeds politely explained that he
wouldn't be capable of killing 682 it's
just too strong when he asked if he
could at least incapacitate 682 he
replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body but this he reminded
would only be a temporary problem for
the lizard another test failed the
foundation brought in
scp-689 a terrifying soapstone statue of
a sitting skeleton that can kill you if
you see it and then stop paying
attention to it 682 first observed the
statue and then the foundation turned
off the lights when they turned them
back on
scp-682 appeared to be dead in a puddle
of gray and black liquid d-class
Personnel were sent in to confirm that
682 was actually dead but it instead got
up and killed them researchers theorized
that 682's definition of life is not
quite the same as ours rendering 689's
death-related Powers ineffective test
failed yet again
scp-807 was next up to bat this is an
anomalous salmon colored ceramic dinner
plate with the words Last Chance Diner
printed on the edges in white any food
placed on it becomes Irresistible by any
definition but when the food is consumed
it causes immediate Cardiac Arrest due
to the sudden clogging of arteries with
fat researchers made a meal known as the
682 special 10 kilograms of rotten Mead
and sharpened bone splinters 10 liters
of rancid mayonnaise 1 liter of
potassium Cyanide and one kilogram of
morphine hydrochloride combined into a
solid mass and transmuted by 807 when
682 consumed this disgusting meal it
appeared to collapse however when
d-class Personnel were sent in again to
see whether 682 was truly out for the
count multiple holes opened up in its
body these holes fired out high pressure
Jets of blood killing the nearby
d-classes and destroying the containment
cell 682 was fine afterwards another
test failed to kill 682 it seemed that
the foundation really needed to have God
on their side so they tried to recruit
scp-343 also known as God to help them
destroy the Beast however when he
entered the containment chamber he
somehow couldn't even see the beast when
researchers asked him whether he could
kill 682 God replied he's not one of
mine deal with him yourself test failed
before it even began next the foundation
recruited
scp-524 a small white rabbit that can
eat literally anything including itself
without being armed the rabbit was
released into scp-682's chamber at which
point it approached 682 and began to eat
one of its legs 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall Out Of 524's Reach
where it remained for a number of hours
at this point scp-524 seemed to become
bored and began eating its way out of
containment through a nearby wall test
failed maybe the Luck of the Irish was
what the foundation needed to finally
put this monster to rest the recruited
scp-1933 a fat man dressed as Santa
Claus whose bodily fluids consist
entirely of the alcoholic beverage known
as Irish cream if enough of this man's
self-produced Irish cream is fed to
something they'll find that all of their
bodily fluids have become Irish cream
too killing them the foundation fed
large quantities of this Irish cream to
scp-682 and it actually had an effect
causing 682 to appear intoxicated which
was a promising sign however it soon
vomited out a massive quantity of
scp-1933 bodily fluids turning the walls
of its cell into Irish cream and
allowing it to escape and wreak havoc
test failed big time the foundation
recruited the help of
scp-2337 an intelligent Corn Creek known
as Dr spenko with a voice so loud it can
quite literally talk its victims to
death if it speaks to them for an
extended period of time it was sent into
scp-682's chamber to attempt to destroy
the beast but 682 just told it to leave
and the talkative bird obliged by
blowing away one of the chamber walls
with a yell allowing scp-682 to breach
containment again terrible job Dr spenko
test failed the foundation researchers
were starting to get a little frustrated
with their lack progress which you can
no doubt sympathize with and they even
pitch the possibility of sending scp-682
into an alternate Dimension where
perhaps it would enter into a stalemate
against its alternate self but this
pitch was shot down by the o5 Council on
the grounds that it was way way way way
way too risky back to the drawing board
by which we mean they literally
transformed 682's skin into a kind of
drawing board
scp-2521 is an anomaly that manifests
anytime information about it is recorded
and immediately grabs the source of the
information wrapping it in its tendrils
and taking it away with it the
foundation sought to take advantage of
this by using a laser cutter to cut this
anomalous information into
scp-682's side however this didn't have
the results they were hoping for
scp-2521 did turn up to take the
information but it only took the skin on
which the information was carved 60 82
survived and quickly grew back its skin
test failed again researchers suggested
tracking down
scp-169 an obscenely massive underwater
creature known as the Leviathan and
feeding 682 to the Beast however this
idea was also immediately shot down by
the o5 council if 682 did what it did
best which was surviving attacks and
adding them to its own Arsenal then it
might grow to the size of
scp-169 which would likely trigger an XK
Class end of the world scenario it
simply was not worth the risk test
failed before it even started the
foundation released two specimens of
scp-939 into 682's test chamber these
voice imitating Amnesia inducing
monsters have caused huge damage to
human targets so it was hoped that they
may be able to do something to 682 but
this hope turned out to be misplaced
both specimens seemed extremely
distressed by 6 82's presence and
refused to engage at all 682 did not
share the same apprehension about
attacking it charged in and brutally
killed both before devouring their
corpses test failed in a very
well-documented case the adorable
scp-999 was introduced into 682's test
chamber The unassailable Good Vibes
provided by 999 as well as an intense
tickle fight did actually lead to the
temporary incapacitation of
scp-682 however the otherwise wholesome
incident ended in tragedy when 682
adapted to the Good Vibes and was able
to release a kind of violent laughter
wave this incapacitated much of the
staff and allowed 682 to breach
containment and go on another Killing
Spree before being recontained test once
again failed the next test involved
scp-294 an anomalous coffee machine that
can produce any liquid typed into its
keypad Foundation researcher is
requested
scp-682 killer from the machine and were
astounded by the results during tests on
the liquid with scp-682 tissue samples
the liquid was surprisingly effective
and caused the 682 tissue to Decay and
crumble tests on the living creature
were similarly promising the acid in
682's tank was temporarily lowered and
one liter of scp-682 killer was poured
onto the reptile's head causing that
portion of its flesh to immediately
Decay when the acid was returned the
same portion that had the liquid poured
on it dissolved instantly test well not
quite successful but promising and
requiring further Research Foundation
scientists believe that if they could
one day get a large enough quantity of
this liquid they might have a viable
option but until then the tests march on
for another experiment they introduced
scp-055 into the containment chamber of
s
scp-055 also known as the self-keeping
secret is a mysterious anomaly that can
only be described by what it isn't for
example we know that scp-055 is not
round but that was pretty much it now
however we know something else about
scp-055 that it can't kill
scp-682 test failed but at least we know
twice as much about scp-055 as we did
before next came
scp-082 better known as Fernand the
cannibal fernan was first presented a
piece of Flesh from 682 but rather than
eating it he inspected it and began to
express joy that his friends still live
when introduced into 682's testing
chamber Ferdinand attempted to subdue
the lizard and use it as his Steed 682
expressed an intense hatred for both
Ferdinand and the idea of being ridden
like a pony and the two of them engaged
in combat mobile task forces were
eventually brought in in to subdue both
subjects in a debrief interview both
hinted that they shared history prior to
containment but 682 was reluctant to
talk about it further test entertaining
but still a failure researchers were
becoming extremely frustrated with
scp-682's unwillingness to die so they
called in an SCP who responded to reason
much better
scp-049 the plague doctor this Sinister
surgeon can kill with a touch and the
foundation hoped that his abilities
would extend to 682 however the result
was a dud the plague doctor did touch
682 but it experienced no adverse
effects and eventually swiped at the
doctor upon leaving 049 reported feeling
emotionally disturbed by his encounter
with
scp-682 yep you guessed it test failed
if he gives you any indication of just
how desperate the researchers were at
this point Dr Graham pondered whether
introducing 682 to a human with just as
pessimistic and misanthropic feelings as
itself would somehow pacify it they sent
in a particularly nasty d-class and the
two spoke fascinatingly 682 didn't
attempt to harm this d-class they just
shared their profane and Bleak
sentiments about the human race with one
another however some of 682's opinions
were a little too spicy for this d-class
after listening to the reptile speak for
20 minutes the d-class fell into a
catatonic state from the sheer
depression of it all he died not long
after one researcher suggested perhaps
the worst idea of all letting scp-682
out into the wild not even really to
terminate it just to see what it does
the scientists figured there would be
some Merit in analyzing the creature's
Behavior this idea was submitted
anonymously of course it seems even the
most sadistic of researchers know better
than to put their name on an idea like
that as you can probably get s this
request was shot down by the o5 council
the note attached to the request by one
of its members summed it up best I'll
tell you what it will do it'll go out
for a nice stroll murder a few innocent
people go fishing slaughter a few more
innocent people start up a tech company
eat a few more innocent people go on a
vacation to Florida dismember a few more
innocent people I swear when I find out
who wrote this you can personally enter
682's containment chamber to analyze him
yourself this has been far from an
exhaustive account of all the different
ways the SCP Foundation has tried to
terminate
scp-682 but it shouldn't be surprising
that all of their ideas have either been
failures or were too risky to even try
sadly for the SCP Foundation and the
human race it's likely we'll be dealing
with scp-682 for a long time to come but
do you have an idea for how you think
682 could finally be killed something
that even the foundation hasn't thought
of to try let us know in the comments
over 50 men and women clad in red robes
kneel before an Unholy altar they chant
and mutter indecipherable words words of
Cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
accountants this was before they fell
under the ungodly influence of a new
ruler the center of this makeshift place
of worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the Beast they worship is
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their God all-powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother Marsh walks among their
crouched forms he whispers instructions
for the great day of Liberation that's
soon to come providing everyone plays
their part it's a plan months in the
making and one that if it goes off
without a hitch could free their
monstrous God into the world they would
strike at the very heart of their enemy
the SCP Foundation when they least
expect it and nothing shall stand in
their way how could they lose when they
have a God on their side but why did all
these normal people become violent
zealots for a squid-faced deity it all
began with a dream to those who
experience these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God hold holding Dominion
overall at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken in afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't every night the
nightmare would return they'd see the
images the Red Sky the dead and Enslaved
the tentacled God and after a while it
would come to them even when they
weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes little
by little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally had purpose they
were working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
rulers sent to them in their dreams they
worshiped together building altars and
Idols to congregate around they
performed dark blood rituals involving
human and animal sacrifice it was when
brother Marsh the anointed one arrived
to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear just
three months prior brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded His
Thoughts with a simple message free me
and the new world I create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
completely to the cause quitting his job
and maxing out his credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the SCP Foundation and releasing his
inhuman ruler from its imprisonment that
was the single goal he United the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
God and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary Intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on Earth even the strongest
institution is made of people and people
are weak unlike the almighty tentacled
God people could be broken the people in
question were Kelly Thompson Sydney
Levitt Jordan brosh Dr Juan Gutierrez
and Jillian Larson Dr Juan Gutierrez was
a researcher with level 3 clearance on
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained Sydney Levitt and Jordan
brosh were both security officers
charged with verifying Personnel
clearance on site Kelly Thompson was a
member of site Administration with
research authorization powers and
Jillian Larson was a research assistant
who often collaborated with Dr Gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to
scp-2662 and bringing their plan
to fruition normally Personnel dossiers
on people working for the foundation
were highly confidential but the
devotees of the tentacled God had their
ways they had a number of computer
experts in their ranks more than capable
of hacking in and pulling some basic
information off of foundation servers
without being detected for the other
information they needed they turned to
some good old-fashioned torture which is
often the most effective method when you
need some quick results of course while
the Colts grip on sanity may have been a
little tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
Task Force Town nine better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping Mall Cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these Foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother Marsh's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock Tau 9 had been charged with
tracking down any new
scp-2662 Cults and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they'd
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming Force the
scp-2662 worshipers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key Foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of Ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their God Dr Gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept Sydney Levitt and
Jordan brosh were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening Thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire Jillian Larson had
seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother Marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two-minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct Forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their Journeys to the site where the
tentacled God was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
SCP Foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one slip
neatly into position disappearing into
the familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on in the ensuing chaos the five
cultists who had already infiltrated the
site could take advantage of the
distraction and break into the
containment chamber
was perfect they launched their attack
from the outside and from within when
brother Marsh declared that the time was
right the assault began a legion of gun
wielding cultists seemed to Spring out
of nowhere and started shooting up the
warehouse that was a front for the
containment site the site quickly
mobilized guards and task force members
to take on the sudden threat and just as
brother Marsh had anticipated the site
director called on the majority of town
9 to help repel the violent cultists
from their perimeter Town 9 obeyed
leaving three task force members behind
a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their God what they didn't
expect was a group of five Foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two Tau 9 members
and taking the third as hostage while
the war was being waged outside the
infiltrators had found the tentacle
God's containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid War their hostage insisted that
you using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662 twice as tall as a regular man
with 10 huge tentacles emerging from its
back in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen still
God's work in mysterious ways so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting
they pulled out a sacrificial dagger and
began sacrificing their captured tau9
member it was at this point that
scp-2662 turned and saw what they were
doing with a look of pure horror he rose
up from his computer his headphones
getting caught as he did so he told them
to go away that he didn't want here and
that them murdering people in this
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor and
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian God to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence Unfortunately they had to
deal with an attempted cult Invasion
every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent Cults who relentlessly
Tracked Down and Worship it with Arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining Town nine
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the SCP Foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept down it's the late 90s and an Air
Canada flight experiences severe
malfunctions while traveling from London
to Vancouver the pilots are unable to do
anything and the plane crashes into the
woods of Northern Alberta the crash was
devastating only 10 of the nearly 300
people on board are alive and even
though they survived the initial
disaster their battle for life has only
just begun it's late autumn in Northern
Canada and there's no telling when help
will arrive if at all if the survivors
want to make it through the night they
need to find shelter and fast as they
trudge through the freezing Woods the
group finds a path that looks like it
might lead them to civilization after
all if there was a path in the woods
that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pond but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algae or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
Thomas Dean who had been on his way back
to his home town of Prince George
British Columbia thought there was
something strangely familiar about this
he remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in Alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to Hell the SCP Foundation was
also aware of this Legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the Air Canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood Pond
when Foundation Personnel intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the Wood Buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by Rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station in epsilon 38 and
put staff on guard to deter travelers
from the area the pond was given the
designation of scp-354 and classed as
Euclid Foundation scientists made a
number of interesting discoveries about
scp-354 when they collected samples for
testing first the pawn was not in fact
full of blood merely an inorganic liquid
that closely resembles blood in color
and consistency second and even Stranger
Than The Red liquid is that the pond
doesn't seem to have any definite Banks
or a bottom instead the liquid in the
pond increases in density as the radius
away from the center increases the
liquid congeals at the edges becoming
more solid and blending into the
surrounding soil it also becomes thicker
as one descends deeper into the pool and
the bottom of the pond has not yet been
reached if it even exists initially the
foundation found no signs of life within
the blood Pond but that would all change
at 203 pm on the day following the
opening of Watch Station Epsilon 38 when
the the science team noticed an unusual
level of activity on the Pond's surface
security footage feed showed a shape
rising out of the pond followed by a
deafening shriek after that the feed was
cut and Foundation lost all
communication with watch station Epsilon
38 fearing the worst a mobile task force
was dispatched to the location when they
got there all Personnel at the watch
station had been killed by what could
only be described as a gigantic bat the
task force was able to neutralize the
entity and as soon as they could the
foundation moved in to increase security
around the SCP creating area 354 and
installing a permanent security detail
after this point the pawn started to
regularly spit out a variety of
monstrous entities almost as if it was
reacting to the SCP foundation's
increased security measures after
scp-354-1 the giant bat came
scp-354-2 354-2 was an echidna-like
monster the size of a bear that was
virtually bulletproof but unable to
escape area 254 the foundation
neutralized this anomaly with Napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy the area's head
scientists was able to hit it with a
sledgehammer causing the sphere to
malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with
scp-354-4 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 feet tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force omega-7 also known as
Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientists at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through o5 believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30 of our total personnel and cut 25
percent of our funding while I can only
hope that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it I worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eerily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory Mission 354 Alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the Pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
McArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Mark with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first two days of the mission but at
4 30 a.m on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say on the fourth day the
ship surfaced proving definitely that
the pond was in fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the portholes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting craft
the other side of the pond was nothing
like the world the crew knew for one
thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Don came and when the Sun finally
Rose it was much larger and redder than
the Earth's sun under the light of the
strange red star the crew could see that
the pond on this side was massive
compared to what they've come into more
like a large lake surrounding the lake
was sand and rocks that were covered in
a kind of moss that disappeared under
sunlight and regrew during the night the
team left the ship and started to
explore during their time in This
Strange World they found that the day
lasted just a few hours shorter than the
night meaning that whatever Planet they
were on had a roughly 43 hour long
rotation as opposed to our own planets
24. the team found a number of anomalous
elements on their expedition including
razor sharp grass that can puncture skin
in streams of liquid carbon dioxide they
heard some loud Roars in the distance
once or twice but other than that the
planet was eerily silent with seemingly
no animal life and not even win when it
rained the soil remained dry and based
on that the scientists theorized the
plants in this world were more efficient
at absorbing moisture on the 25th day
the team ran into a huge metal wall that
appeared to be artificially constructed
luckily Leroy Tucker a quick thinking
researcher was able to rig a blowtorch
from camping supplies and melt a hole
through the metal on the other side
there was finally wind and odd black
grass that's the extent of what is known
about the other side of the wall because
the Expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
day a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354 the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
354. it was apparent that there had been
some kind of mutiny within the site and
that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated MTF Theta 12 and no further
contact with the former Personnel of
area 354 has been made since following
the site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned with containment the shift in
directive came as a response to the
Pond's apparent reactive nature each
creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
Area 3 5 4 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood Pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
Pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential Personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to Escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pond isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the SCP Foundation have only served
to annoy it and worst studies of the
ponds banks have proved evidence that
the area of congealed liquid around the
perimeter of the pond has been steadily
expanding that's right the pond is
getting bigger the last thing the
foundation agent stationed at the site
said before being dragged out of the
interview and sedated was it gets bigger
and stronger every day and now we've
made it Angry The Entity that is
scp-4840-a is an old man who calls
himself the caretaker of the floating
city of odedopodopolis he holds secrets
that will change the foundation's
understanding of the world forever the
old man was initially encountered by
Captain Francis Pike who first explored
adapadopoulos for the foundation it was
here that scp-4840 provided some insight
into the City and its Mysteries over a
decade later the foundation has sent Dr
Val ostorovich to interview the old man
unbeknownst to her everything she and
everyone else thinks they know is about
to change
scp-4840-a walks into the room where Dr
osterovic sits please take a seat she
says to the old man he looks around at
the barren stone walls and takes a few
steps into the center of the room Dr
osterovic motions to the chair across
the table from her the old man pulls the
chair out and takes a seat Dr osterovic
leans over and pushes a button on the
voice recorder resting on the table
that's very impressive the old man says
examining the device so it records
everything I say that is correct
responds Dr osterovic the old man looks
around the room and then directly into
her eyes a smile cracks his lips I
wondered when the foundation would want
to cause like actually talk you are a
seeker of knowledge you reminded me a
little of my brother he may have been
the greatest scholar that ever lived and
now you seek the truth for that we will
need to take a journey billions of years
billions that's Dr rosterovic billions
the old man answers folding his hands
onto the table I was there from the
beginning the old man begins to tell his
tale it is so vividly worded that Dr
osterovic feels like she is living in
the story like she's been transported to
a different time and place to experience
the creation of the universe and the
fall of Man in the beginning there was
light the iron God manifested itself his
sword cut flaming Stars into the sky the
god of Flesh sprinkled drops of blood
onto the Earth creating the first life
The Serpent of sin and its Stark brother
laid the foundation for what is and what
is not a young boy looked up at the sky
as the Earth began to turn he watched
the creation of everything from the
Great Hall of adidasopoulos this was
where humans were born wait I don't
understand says Dr osterovic are you
telling me that Adidas is like the
Garden of Eden I am not telling you that
it is like anything the old man says
with a wink but I think you want to
learn more about a different tale
something I will get to in time in the
early days of the universe there were
only a few humans in existence for
millions of years they watched through
the haze of creation to learn more about
the reality they were born into they
built the very first city and upon
completion it became the spot where that
which is came to be there were only ever
two true Gods is and is not they were
the only truths in the entire universe
is brought the serpent into the world it
searched for once it came and to learn
about all the truths that had been
hidden from it the is not was the darker
shadow of is it controlled everything
that stretched out beyond the world and
into the unknown the two Gods could not
exist without one another when you refer
to to the serpent do you mean the entity
that resides in The Wanderers Library
interjects Dr osterovic one and the
shame replies the old man it was during
the time after the is and is not
finished creation but the monsters and
demons inhabited the Earth however there
was order the monsters of other worlds
were kept separate these entities would
be in the dreams of men but were never
able to cross over to their world it was
the strange folk to the west of
anadopadopoulos that first opened their
eyes to the cosmos they were created
from the last remnants of the is but
were not human they were something that
could not be explained by Logic the
humans were looked after by the mothers
of the newly created world the wolf the
bear the sow and the lion were their
protectors as the days went on and more
men and women walked the streets of
Adidas they met in the Great Hall of the
city where they would seek counsel and
listen to the first king of men his name
was Asim which came from the word that
meant is his skin looked as if it were
made of gold and he had power beyond
imagining although a sem was only a man
he could create mountains with his hands
and deep oceans with his feet he had a
lance that could kill even the gods asem
was a great leader but deep inside of
him grew the first vice of men Envy he
would look to the heavens and desired
them to be his humans had built the
greatest City that would ever be and yet
the king wanted more so he took it as
sem was the first being to seize
something from a world that was not his
own he stole a crown and when he
gathered the inhabitants of
adidasopoulos to the Great Hall to show
them his New Relic he declared himself
the king of all that is he built a seat
of power on top of the spot where
mankind first found is as Sam was still
kind to the people of Adidas
but he always desired more then the
great betrayals came asem's Sons grew up
in the shadow of their father's Envy the
first betrayal was by his middle son who
coveted his father's Crown he demanded
that it be passed on to him and when SM
refused the son amassed an army and laid
Siege to the world but the middle son
was struck down by his father and locked
in a stone tomb deep under the grounds
of Adidas the second betrayal came from
sm's oldest son he went behind his
father's back and spoke passionately to
the people using sense and reason to
demand that they make his father give in
the crown the people of Earth worshiped
assem's oldest son as if he were a god
seeing this asem removed the poison that
his eldest son had put into their minds
he then dealt with him by casting his
son to the most desolate place on Earth
where he would wander until the sun went
down in the East the most devastating
betrayal of all came from the youngest
son of asean he came into his father's
bedroom while he slept and took the
crown from his head the youngest son and
his followers ran away with the crown
when a Sam awoke his heart broke with
what his youngest son whom he loved more
than anyone or anything in the entire
world had done an endless rage welled up
in the king and he turned the earth into
a smoking Wasteland a Sam searched
tirelessly for his youngest Offspring
and the crown his Envy knew no bounds
and he desired nothing more than for his
crown to be returned to him for
thousands of years Assam searched but
could not find what he was looking for
the crown had been hidden away and
slowly faded into Legend the world
gradually returned to normal Fields
began to regrow and Forest sprouted from
the smoldering Embers of the planet's
wide siege that a sem had carried out in
search of his crown the followers of his
youngest son spread across the region
which would later become known Asura
then came the time of endless Wars men
fought demons and monsters men fought
one another from these wars came the
deaths of many and the ancient ruins
that have long since been consumed by
the Sands of the Earth but these wars
would lead to the current age of human
history during the Great Wars one man
hid and watched from the Great Hall at
adapadopoulos he witnessed the world
consume itself but the worst was yet to
come zorus the Sky King found his way to
adedopodopolis and demanded that he be
given the Lance of SM however the lands
had been lost long ago with the fall of
the first king of man as he ravaged the
planet looking for his crown zorus
refused to believe that the Lance was
not in the city and began to destroy
adedopodopolis as he looked for it but
before zorus could completely demolish
everything a hidden Mystery was called
upon to stop the threat the last of the
titans the Great Dragon bahrath
slumbered beneath the city emerged from
the earth and carried adedopodopolis
into the sky forever separating it from
the men of the world you mean until the
foundation discovered it since Dr
osterovic well yes and no replies the
old man there was one before you the
history of man progressed Deva hero of
Gilgamesh killed Sarah's 2's only son in
single Combat on the fields of Jerusalem
the dreaded sorcerer Noah El menthof
flooded the lands until he was killed by
malidro the raffle jorai apollon sailed
across the Great Sea to meet with the
king of the night children but was
buried alive to feed the heart of their
tree goddess then from the East came
Lancelot like the night from King
Arthur's Knights of the Round Table as
Dr osterovic the old man frowns no that
was a different Lancelot the one who
came to the floating city was called the
demon Lancelot as the demon lancelots
approached adapadopoulos any training
allies who still walked the Earth were
called upon for assistance the evil Army
that the demon commanded would not be
easily defeated Lancelot first Target
batrada the old Dragon who had lifted
odedapadopoulos into the skies next he
battled the Sea Lord arcturius he made
quick work of the hero Beowulf and
lastly fell the king of David all that
remained between the demon Lancelot and
the City of Adidas padopoulos was one
human he took up his sword and battled
the demon but Lancelot was too strong
the demon used the flails attached to
his six arms to demolish anything in his
path he was about to land the deadly
blow when with its last breath the
dragon bathrata ripped the demon
lancelot's heart out of his chest and
cast him into the Temple of sunset where
his dead body lies to this day all was
now quiet in anadopadopoulos the gods
and heroes of old had been lost or were
hidden away the search for the crown
continued on and even Asen himself is
somewhere scouring the Earth for his
precious Relic the floating city of
odded apodopolis was forgotten so
basically most of the scps that the
foundation contains come straight from
your history Dr osterovic says yes I
believe you are correct replies the old
man just from the story alone there must
be entities you recognize and the fact
that many of the Gods early men and
demons are Immortal means you will
probably hear more about them in time
the demon Lancelot may seem dead but his
body still radiates heat I feel it is
only a matter of time until we must do
battle once again okay there is
something I don't understand Dr
osterovic says the old man nods at her
where do you fit into the story I
understand you were there at creation
but you know so much and I can't help
but feel you are leaving something out
the old man pauses he lets out a long
sigh by name is Seth the old man says
brother to Cain and Abel son of Adam
Ellison the first king of men I was the
king's youngest who stole the crown I
was the one who looked at the night sky
and asked my father for a star all my
own he pulled one out of the heavens for
me and it became the iron Crown it drove
my father to Madness my brothers to
Butchery and led to the ruination of our
kingdom the crown is the seed at the
root of all evil Seth stares blankly
across the room and it was meant as a
gift for me it sailed through space at
an unimaginable speed a grand mechanical
construction unlike anything we'd ever
seen on our planet a terrifying weapon
to end all weapons Oppenheimer said of
the atomic bomb now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds but
comparatively this device made the atom
bomb look like little more than a cherry
bomb this deadly machine's orders were
simple take a direct course to Earth
activate and wipe out all life leave the
planet Baron with not even the smallest
squirming microbes remaining and this
device this Destroyer was more than
capable of accomplishing this task it'd
been smooth sailing for millions of
miles all Diagnostics were looking
positive within a mere decade or so the
human race would be purged from the
cosmos then faster than the
pre-programmed Destroyer could react a
huge huge yellowish green shape appeared
in front of it the destroyer's
mysterious creators in their not quite
infinite intelligence had planned for
all of the major celestial bodies in
Earth's solar system including Jupiter
but for reasons unknown they hadn't
calculated the presence of IO Jupiter's
third largest Galleon Moon the Destroyer
Struck it at incredible speed causing a
mighty explosion and completely altering
its perfect trajectory alarms were
sounding as the Destroyer hurled down
onto the lower atmosphere of Jupiter
this alteration was unprecedented mayday
mayday in some distant galaxies screams
were flashing red and the Creator
suddenly registered that this mission
may not be so simple after all they
would need to make adjustments the
impact into Jupiter triggered the
destroyer's attack protocol drawing from
its Limitless energy source it activated
its hyper-advanced anti-matter Weaponry
causing spatial disruptions and atmosph
rear shifts that created a huge red
Vortex on the surface of the gas giant
one that would later become known to
earth-based astronomers as the Great Red
Spot it's 16 350 kilometers wide which
is 1.3 times the size of planet Earth
and it exists as a kind of hell that
almost no being could endure a constant
swirling nightmare with 432 kilometer
per hour wind speeds in other words the
exact kind of nightmare it would have
turned Earth into if ever it had reached
its actual intended destination but no
matter this was just a minor setback all
things considered such contingencies had
been planned for from the start the
creators back in the triangulum Galaxy
roughly 3 million light years away from
the Milky Way simply began transmitting
new orders to the crashed malfunctioning
Destroyer unit is damaged repair and
that's exactly what it began to do it's
unknown how they were able to
communicate let alone travel over such a
vast distance but systems that would be
impossible to even explain to humans
suddenly began to kick in it released a
legion of hearty self-made octopod
repair drones that began to search for
the machine's missing parts presumably
hidden within the gases of Jupiter or
pulled in by the gravity of its nearby
moons other drones would remain at the
destroyer's side conducting repairs and
guiding its vital systems presumably to
this machine and its creators humans are
like mayflies insignificant creatures
with such tiny lifespans here today gone
tomorrow the machine would conduct its
repairs and be upon us within a mere few
centuries barely even diverting from the
schedule the one thing the creators
didn't anticipate was the formation of a
little organization called the SCP
Foundation perhaps the only hope
Humanity has in repelling this doomsday
weapon the question we need to answer
today is will they be enough
terrifyingly this device has been intent
on our destruction since long before the
SCP Foundation was even a glint in
Humanity's eye it entered our solar
system and crashed on Jupiter all the
way back in
1665. we know this thanks to the
writings of Italian astronomer Giovanni
Cassini who recorded detailed notes in
his journal on what we would later dub
scp-2399 on October 8 1665 he wrote I
have observed the something
extraordinary in the heavens the last
night as I gazed through my looking
glass I saw what appeared to be a star
of great luminescence straight through
the far reaches of our solar system I
have never recorded an object moving so
fast it had surpassed the outer planets
in fewer than two hours as I watched by
my own two eyes I sat slow as it closed
on Jupiter make a sharp turn and
disappear into the planet itself I saw
many bursts of light afterwards but
although I could continue to peer at it
until the sun broke I saw no additional
disturbances in the night sky I must
continue to document that these changes
and will alert my colleagues when the
day is upon me on October 15th I took
Peter to my observation pointer last
night but the weaker from the last night
I saw the fire rained upon Jupiter and
the heavens he brought along his owner
Looking Glass and together we aimed our
view upon the giant to our surprise a
magnificent change had occurred where
once the distant world only showed bands
of color there was now a great red spot
where the star came to rest on the
surface of a Jupiter Peter was
incredulous of course that such an
amazing Discovery could have taken place
before our very eyes I will continue to
take note of this on October 18th the
night as I peered through my looking
glass I swear on my life that I observed
what I Look to me like explosions and
Starbursts emanating from our red spot I
fear My Mind is Playing Pricks on me for
there has been no record of such a
violent outer burst by a Heavenly Body
since the dawn of astronomy I will
consulted with Peter on the model and
hopefully glean from him some advice on
the matter on October 19th Peter sees
the same as I as I approach him with my
concerns he leveled the scene with me
and through our following discussion we
concluded that there must be a powerful
reaction to the falling star I saw upon
the first night and not the product of
our own shortcomings I am left wondering
what cataclysmic event must be taking
place upon our Heavenly neighbor I work
to document this must go on and the work
of documenting
scp-2399 has indeed gone on for
centuries just as the machine itself has
never once ceased in its extensive
repairs it was first spotted by modern
humanity and by extent mentioned the SCP
Foundation in 1963. as soon as the
technology existed to send satellites up
to Jupiter the foundation began studying
this frightening new foe up close trying
to get the true measure of its abilities
they discovered that the weapon has a
mysterious internal power supply that
seems impossible to run down as well as
an advanced targeting system self-repair
abilities anti-matter weapons and matter
disrupting capabilities it also appears
to have advanced shielding systems that
make destroying it currently impossible
and seeing as it's a massive piece of
military Machinery
514.18 Million Miles Away From Earth
it's impossible to truly contain that's
why the foundation has rearranged its
priorities into two new prongs regarding
scp-2399 the first is suppressing
information to avoid panic in order to
achieve this the foundation has embedded
agents in all major observatories to
suppress any sightings of the machine
and has also been conducting an active
disinformation campaign to keep it out
of the public Consciousness the second
prong of their containment procedure is
cutting off the Transmissions between
the destroyer's creators in the
triangulum galaxy and the Destroyer
itself actually achieving this goal took
a miraculous feat in aerospace
engineering the barrier satellite array
this was an unprecedented long-range
satellite array positioned in Jupiter's
higher orbit designed for the specific
purpose of blocking the electromagnetic
Transmissions inbound for the Destroyer
these messages are intercepted decoded
and logged on the foundation Database
The Satellites have also been granted
some minor offensive capabilities for
use in extreme emergencies
scp-2399 has been given the ketter class
due to its unique containment
difficulties it's also been given
disruption class Amita for the Hefty
possibility that reaching Earth could
result in an SK class Barren Earth end
of the world scenario on top of that it
has been given the risk class danger due
to the very high potential of all this
actually coming to pass the biggest
concern for the foundation at present is
the accelerating rate of repair that the
Destroyer seems to be exhibiting back
when they first observed the Destroyer
up close it was repairing itself at a
rate of 0.12 percent however that rate
of repair has now risen to 0.78 annually
according to all known metrics its
current level of functionality appears
to be 59 percent if it ever reaches 75
percent then to put it mildly we're all
going to be in a lot of trouble current
projections say this is incredibly
likely to occur in the next 25 years and
if we don't figure out a way to stop it
before then the Earth is doomed the SCP
Foundation received a chilling wake-up
call about the severity of the situation
when one of the barrier units noticed
one of the destroyer's repair drones
zeroing in on a piece of debris that
seemed to be part of the Destroyers
communications array considering that
the foundation's main weapon against the
Destroyer right now is blocking its
communication capabilities allowing it
to repair its communications array would
be an unacceptable failure because of
this barrier unit 53 was ordered to fire
its onboard concussion batteries at the
Drone in hopes of destroying it or at
least impeding its progress this was met
by Swift and severe prevention and
retaliation from the Destroyer it fired
its own defensive charges destroying
barrier unit 53's payload five
kilometers away from the repair drone it
subsequently destroyed barrier unit 53
as well as several other barrier
satellites that just so happened to be
in its vicinity this led to an order
that no barrier units are permitted to
engage the repair drones for fear that
this would lead to even greater losses
the next attempt to fight back against
scp-2399 went by the name project gigas
this was a joint project between the SCP
Foundation and 45 of different nations
with the goal of using sheer raw
Firepower to destroy or at least utterly
incapacitate
scp-2399 they would Place almost 100
massive nuclear warheads on Europa
Jupiter's smallest Galilean Moon each
one fitted with EMP detonators to impede
the destroyer's defense systems they
would hit it with so much nuclear
Hellfire that it surely would be
destroyed naturally when this failed to
meaningfully damage the Destroyer the
foundation returned to the drawing board
daunted by the enormity of the task
before them the way they saw it there
was only one viable option left protocol
Legionnaire Randall McAllen the director
of the barrier project released the
following haunting memo on the subject
so
scp-2399 have you ever sat and wondered
maybe after you hear about a car
accident on a street you were just on or
a bombing in a city you were visiting
just how lucky you are to be alive
just how many things have to go right
for you to continue to exist a few
seconds too late a few seconds too early
and somebody reaches for something they
dropped and a busload of people run into
another busload of people sometimes this
kind of thing does happen as we've seen
far too often but that's what we're here
for to protect those who can't protect
themselves from things that they
wouldn't even know to protect themselves
from we can't do it all though as many
things as we've been able to contain as
many things as we've been able to keep
under lock that would threaten to
destroy us all still far too many remain
that we can't do anything about whether
they're too big or too fast or too
powerful any of these things could blink
and wipe Humanity from existence the
fact that they haven't done so yet is
just luck
scp-2399 is however different we have
little information regarding
scp-2399's motives Origins and full
capabilities we do not understand how it
is capable of communicating over such
large distances or why those who
constructed it if it was in fact
instructed sent it to us in the first
place we do not know what would happen
if scp-2399 is able to fully repair
itself or if part of our array would
break down and any message would get
through we do not know this so we must
assume the worst judging by what we've
seen where scp-2399 to have reached
Earth it would have led to our timely
destruction but sometimes Humanity gets
a little help sometimes something steps
in the way of the Apocalypse for us and
for
scp-2399 it was Jupiter as scp-2399
began to slow on its approach to Earth
Cassini saw what we've been able to
ascertain that scp-2399 struck IO was
damaged and was unable to escape the
gravitational pull of Jupiter its
weapons activated as they were intended
but it was Jupiter that experienced
doomsday not us eventually though it is
likely the that scp-2399 will resume
full functionality and will likely be
able to pull away from Jupiter and
proceed to its Target as of now we can
keep hurtling bombs and emps at it all
we want but we've got no indication that
any of it will so much as scratch the
thing on the contrary experience
dictates that it would do nothing at all
if this were to happen now we would
undoubtedly be destroyed Jupiter has
given us some time for now
scp-2399 will remain there reassembling
itself while we devise some way to stop
it like it or not we are in an arms race
with this thing our best guess is give
us something like 25 years until it is
able to hear past or dampening array
until then we must seize the opportunity
that has been laid before us we must use
the time we have been given and not let
it be wasted so we devised protocol
Legionnaire one gigantic EMP
powered by God knows what followed by a
volley of nukes big enough to wipe out
our civilization a thousand times over a
blunt plan and simple and likely futile
our researchers and researchers around
the globe have yet to devise even a way
to deliver that kind of pulse let alone
a way to power it there is no indication
whatsoever that we will be able to
complete legionnaire on time or if it
will do what it is intended once it is
completed but we must try we must do
something even if we have to drain our
banks and empty our minds we must try
not often do we get the chance to see
the swerving bus that will end our lives
and step out of the way Jupiter
unknowingly has offered us that chance I
suggest we take it you're probably
wondering why is McAllen approaching
this situation with such desperate
urgency while it's because in 1996 and
again in 2015 the message that the
Destroyer has been receiving changed it
was no longer a simple order to repair
the message now read
and if that message ever gets through
time is already up for all of us can a
thought be infectious is it possible
that transferring an idea can happen as
easily as catching the common cold
someone gets it then transmits it to
another person who then passes it on to
someone else and so on imagine for a
moment that information is a disease we
can't see information or feel it we can
read it in books or on the internet but
actually seeing it or feeling it inside
our heads is impossible so what if
something could taint the information we
absorb use it to slip its way undetected
into your mind then pass from you to
your friends your family your co-workers
how would you know it was there and how
could you prevent it from getting into
your head perhaps it's time you are
introduced to
scp-3002 over its many years of studying
and containing a anomalous beings and
entities the SCP Foundation has
encountered a number of creatures with
memetic abilities if you are unfamiliar
with the term memetic usually refers to
data or information that has been
manipulated in order to influence or
subconsciously change a person's
Behavior this can take any form from
text and images to spoken phrases and
other audio for example a form of
memetic influence we have all
experienced at some point is product
placement if you ever watched a
character in a movie or on TV using a
certain product then that may have made
you decide that you want to buy that
same product for yourself that idea was
planted in your head by something you
saw and had a subliminal influence on
your behavior
scp-3002 is one such entity that uses
memetic stimuli for its own nefarious
purposes some anomalies like
scp-2440 use memetic information to
spread knowledge of themselves among
human beings getting stronger than the
more people learn about it
scp-3002 on the other hand is
information this entity is a thought a
living sentient thought with a number of
abilities that allow it to influence the
minds of human beings it is hard to
picture a thought let alone one that is
alive since we can't see information the
idea of something so abstract having a
tangible form boggles the mind
scp-3002 is capable of shape-shifting
and while it does not possess its own
consistent shape the entity is able to
transform itself into the form of any
piece of information it chooses existing
is pure information means that it is
intangible to any beings that possess
physical bodies but what makes scp-30002
a threat to everyone at the foundation
and earned this entity its ketter
classification is its power to
manipulate a person's mind or memories
allowing scp-3002 to directly enter
human mines moving at the speed the
thoughts can travel through the brain
this entity is almost impossible to kill
or kept contained
scp-3002 can spread like a sickness
through a human population attacking new
minds and taking control of its victims
according to the foundation's research
there is only one way to remove the
influence of scp-3002 anyone that comes
under the control of this entity has to
undergo complex intricate and risky
brain surgery in order to physically
remove the entity from their minds
however the foundation considers this
method to be impractical time-consuming
cost ineffective and is rendered utterly
pointless if scp-3002 has infected too
much of a subject's mind so instead in
order to prevent the spread of
scp-3002's influence all Foundation
Personnel are instructed to terminate
any person contaminated by this living
thought this order is extended to that
individual's family friends colleagues
and even acquaintances given that
scp-3002 can take the form of any
information it chooses written words a
sound even a telepathic signal anyone
even remotely linked to someone The
Entity infects has to be destroyed to
stop any potential spread if you or
anyone you knew were to come into
contact with scp-3002 the entity would
be able to take control of your entire
Consciousness all your memories would be
ripe for the entities picking
scp-3002 is able to sift through your
temporal lobe where memories are stored
and can not only destroy and delete an
infected person's memories but can also
create false memories to replace them
and all the while you would be
completely unaware that this was
happening to you stripped of all your
natural survival instincts while
scp-3002 runs riot in your brain there
is currently no known limit to how much
of someone's mind scp-3002 is able to
mimic rewrite alter or remove when the
entity Alters one of your memories that
memory will become an additional
instance of
scp-3002 in other words it can implant
itself in every moment of your life
making itself a part of everything you
remember about your own personal past
and even the parts you can't once
scp-3002 has spread itself to every
piece of information stored inside your
brain the next stage of infection begins
an scp-3002 is able to take full control
of a person's body much like before this
could be happening to you without you
ever being consciously aware of it
usually this doesn't come too much and
infected victims will carry on their
day-to-day lives acting no different to
how they would normally that is until
scp-3002 detects a new Target that
hasn't been infected yet when this
happens any people previously exposed to
scp-3002 will collectively seek out the
uncontaminated individual capturing them
once this happens as
scp-3002's infected Army will force
their new victim to join them the SCP
Foundation considers scp-3002 to be
extremely hostile and a major threat to
their organization and the World At
Large due to scp-3002 being
uncontainable unable to infinitely adapt
it has evaded capture or termination for
a considerable length of time having the
ability to spread among human beings via
the information we share with each other
speech texts emails phone calls any
information at all means that
potentially any and all information
could contain as CP 3002 according to
calculations of the foundation's top
researchers 78 of humanity may be under
the influence of
scp-3002 without any awareness that they
have been infected while dangerous and
Unstoppable
scp-3002 doesn't operate purely on
Instinct it doesn't infect as many Minds
as it can just because it knows no other
way everything that scp-3002 does is a
premeditated calculated decision with
one nefarious intention one goal to
destroy the SCP Foundation From the
Inside Out by killing or infecting every
member of personnel Believe It or Not
scp-3002 didn't begin life as a sentient
infectious thought in fact
scp-3002 was once a person a regular
human being like you or I she even had a
name Lily the selka it is widely
believed that Lily vasilka became what
we now know as scp-3002 due to the
actions of the foundation itself since
becoming scp-3002 Lily seems to have
been searching for any information she
can find regarding a highly secret
operation conducted by the SCP
Foundation known as project Lethy as
well as this she appears to have an
interest in a number of foundation
research facilities including site e and
an off the books facility located in
Ukraine's yuseninski National Park this
is potentially where
scp-3002 was first created if any of
this is to be believed then it would
certainly explain
scp-3002's noticeable aggression towards
the foundation and its attempts to
infect its personnel as an act of
Revenge after the project that turned
Lily into a living thought
scp-3002 was later encountered by the
foundation in its current form in South
Rock Penitentiary this prison located
near Lafayette Indiana was first visited
by one Dr Daryl Lloyd one of the SCP
foundation's researchers the prison
psychiatrist a woman named Dr Suzanne
Fairbank was the first to notice the
effects of scp-3002 contamination on a
number of South Rock penitentiary's
inmates during sessions with her several
of these prisoners had mentioned an
identical memory to Dr Fairbank the
description of the memory from each of
the in inmates followed the same
structure The Prisoner remembered taking
a long walk through a forest with their
best friend at the time this detail the
best friend is most likely scp-3002
herself imitating a figure from each
inmate's own childhood memories at some
point in this false shared memory all
the prisoners were called having an
argument with their friend it was later
learned that the figure was Lily viselka
approaching infected individuals in
their memories to ask them questions
about the project that had turned her
into
scp-3002 often demanding to know what do
you know about me or has the project
finished the foundation began to
investigate this bizarre instance of
shared anomalous memory after Dr Suzanne
Fairbanks shared her findings on an
internet Message Board describing what
she had witnessed to other psychology
experts at first Dr Lloyd the
foundation's researchers sent to South
Rock to gather more information labeled
the situation as low priority research
given us
cp3002's ability to adapt and take the
form of any information it was able to
avoid immediate detection by the SCP
Foundation and the full extent of Lily's
abilities remained hidden Dr Lloyd
originally classified as cp3002 is safe
believing it was a little more than a
shared childhood memory that the South
Rock inmates had described at first
those that had been infected with this
Collective memory were able to recount
it with perfect accuracy but as Dr Lloyd
continued to interview and test the
affected inmates the details became
scarier and the memory became less and
less defined the further the SCP
Foundation looked into it perhaps Lily
recognized the foundation's presence and
remembered that they were the ones
responsible for turning her into a
sentient memetic entity without physical
form and started hiding her tracks maybe
she was biting herself time hiding
herself away in the minds of the
infected prisoners until the time was
right little did Dr Lloyd realize that
time just how far
scp-3002's influence had already spread
Lily wasn't just in the inmates heads
but almost all of the prison staff too
who were now spreading her further and
further without even realizing it
thinking that scp-3002 would be easy to
contain Dr Lloyd had the foundation
administer and me sticks to all the
infected inmates amnestics are memory
altering drugs that the SCP Foundation
uses to prevent any information about
scps becoming known to the public when
dealing with memetic anomalies like
scp-3002 or
scp-2440 amnestics can be particularly
useful in removing a person's memories
about a memetic SCP Dr Lloyd hoped that
this would be the case at South Rock
still thinking as cp3002 was nothing
more than an anomalous shared memory
that could be removed however removing
the false memory that Lily had implanted
in the prisoners would not remove her
from all their other memories
additionally one of the affected inmates
was not given amnestics and was brought
back to the foundation for observation
from their scp-3002's influence had been
able to spread like a sickness through
the ranks of the foundation's own
Personnel without their knowledge or
detection every person whose mind as
cp3002 is able to reach becomes an
unwitting carrier for the Infectious
living thought it is unknown exactly how
many of the SCP foundation's members are
under the control of scp-3002 granting
Lily access to the wealth of secret
information and plans that the
foundation keeps hidden it doesn't
matter what level of clearance someone
would need to view it if it's
information it's another way for
scp-3002 to spread and information as we
know can take any form be it a written
file a spoken conversation or even an
informative YouTube video now tell me
again about the time that we took a walk
together in the forest when you see some
of the monsters in entities they try to
contain it's easy to think of the SCP
Foundation as the good guys and granted
When You observe the magnitude of
threats like the Scarlet King it's hard
for anyone to not look like a downright
moral Paragon in comparison but the
foundation aren't always knights in
shining armor sometimes they themselves
have committed horrific atrocities in
order to keep their Supernatural
subjects under wraps and keep the rest
of us safe from anomalous Terror nowhere
is that more clear than a deadly
incident that occurred in 2010 the
foundation had been aware of the Slow
Burn sloth for decades and many believe
that the entity has existed for as long
as human beings have consumed visual
media movies TV web pages and even print
media like books and magazines are
vulnerable technically speaking the name
scp-2774 refers to whatever visual
medium is currently holding the true
entity known as scp-2770 4-a thankfully
scp-2774-a has never made it onto the
internet where it could do truly
catastrophic damage but the foundation
has prepared for that possibility
they've invented a software program web
crawler a03 g32 designed to constantly
monitor all forms of online visual media
for an appearance of
scp-2774-a so what is
scp-2774-a what could possibly be so
scary that even a picture of it leaking
onto the internet could potentially lead
to the collapse of human civilization
simply put
scp-2774-a is this image of an unknown
humanoid entity in a bizarre sloth
costume while this picture may seem
harmless that's only because it's black
and white and any red or green Hues have
been neutralized from the image anyone
who isn't red green colorblind and
somehow accidentally sees the true
version of scp-27
774-a has a fate far worse than death in
store for them this is the same fate
that would befall almost the entire
population of the northern Canadian town
of Harper Ridge in 2010. the residents
of this small Township were waking up
and going about their morning some were
getting ready for work others enjoying a
leisurely breakfast in front of the
television set all of those affected had
unknowingly made the deadly mistake of
watching the local news that morning
while the anchor droned on about some
Local Economic statistics and delivered
a dry advertisement for an upcoming town
Festival The Familiar image of something
in the sloth costume appeared briefly on
the set behind him most of the Harper
Ridge residents who viewed the broadcast
didn't even notice the sloth but in that
fateful instant almost every single one
of them was doomed the Slow Burn sloth
doesn't always affect everyone who sees
it Foundation scientists have found that
it generally only affects 40 of people
exposed to it and doesn't affect those
suffering from colorblindness at all
however one of the more frightening
details about the sloth which is
classified as a memetic image SCP for
its ability to spread and appear
randomly almost anywhere is that it
grows more powerful and more contagious
with every living victim it affects
after claiming a significant number of
new victims say from a small Canadian
Town
scp-2774-a's infection rate can rise to
as high as 60 percent or beyond the
residents of Harper Ridge made their own
Predator deadlier without even knowing
it at a nearby Foundation facility units
were already mobilizing it was too late
for those who had already seen the Slow
Burn sloth but others could potentially
be saved if the situation was contained
quickly in addition to the web crawler
constantly monitoring the internet the
SCP Foundation also had a huge number of
dedicated team scanning broadcasts
worldwide for potential instances of
scp-2770 4-a exposure when one of these
teams detected the sloth's presence in
Harper's ridge's morning newscast and
found that upwards of 4 000 civilians
had already been exposed they knew there
was no time to waste back in Harper
Ridge the situation was already
deteriorating a few hours had passed
since the broadcast and those who were
exposed were beginning to experience
strange symptoms already first it was a
sense of tiredness and lethargy then an
unusual heaviness to their body as
though they were experiencing sudden
extreme muscle fatigue people exposed to
scp-2774-a also experienced clouded
cognition even thinking straight became
a real struggle it was at this point
that the true effects of witnessing the
Slow Burn sloth began to take hold
around six hours after initial exposure
little by little the infected lost all
cognitive functions and higher level
decision-making abilities their bodies
still acted out basic movements very
slowly
seemingly just as a result of muscle
memory but they had no control over what
was going on they became essentially
living zombies trapped in their own
bodies and only dimly aware of it this
horrifying experience was completely
consistent with prior Foundation
Research into the effects of viewing
scp-2774-a and in a Twist almost crueler
than permanent zombification victims of
the Slow Burn sloth are randomly
allocated around 150 seconds of Lucidity
every 24 hours before being forced back
into their zombified state just as four
thousand of Harper ridge's residents
were beginning to experience these
effects all local communication channels
to the town were cut off by the
foundation well-equipped teams of mobile
task force operators began arriving on
the scene shortly after accompanied by a
number of containment units in the form
of buses and trucks lucky for them the
zombified victims of the Slow Burn sloth
were incredibly docile and compliant by
nature shepherding all four thousand of
them into the containment units were
almost like working with cattle some
non-infected local residents attempted
to protest the sudden Abduction of their
zombified loved ones these residents
were subdued and either had their
memories wiped with Foundation amnestics
or were terminated on site like with
almost any conceivable situation the SCP
Foundation already had measures in place
for a mass exposure event like this all
in all a mere 4000 was still on the low
end of the potential infection scale the
four thousand victims were secretly
taken to site 116 a foundation testing
site under the direction of Dr Martin
and his second in command Dr Clara Chong
there they'd already been pursuing
research on approximately 2 400 infected
subjects from prior incidents including
Foundation Personnel who were
accidentally infected during the
monitoring process thus far it seemed
that the condition caused by witnessing
the Slow Burn sloth was incurable and
with 6400 known living victims situated
at site 116.
scp-2774-a was at an unprecedented level
of power all site Personnel were
instructed to proceed with caution and
carefully observe the behavior of their
new test subjects Dr Chung spearheaded
the majority of the Hands-On Research
into the infected residents of Harper
Ridge and observe some interesting
phenomenon in the victim's behavioral
patterns as the condition escalated the
infected subjects even in their largely
zombified State developed an almost
fanatically religious obsession with the
image of the Slow Burn sloth when left
to their own devices they would create
Idols of
scp-2774-a these included amateur
sculptures made of hoarded garbage
images drawn of the sloth with any
materials they could get their hands on
or even writing obsessively about the
sloth Dr Chung speculated that this
Behavior was perhaps an act of
appeasement on the victim's part hoping
to somehow save the Slow Burn sloth and
lessen its effects on them through
worship however she would later find out
that the truth of the matter was far
more disturbing initially due to their
largely docile States the subjects
imprisoned in site 116 were given a
relatively Long Leash the subjects were
even allocated two hours a day for
social interaction with fellow subjects
at meal times and during a designated
recreational period during these times
the subjects would often trade their
Slow Burn sloth Effigies with one
another however Dr Chung revoked the
social interaction periods and began
confining the subjects to separate
euclid-class containment cells when
violence began to break out between them
it became clear that during their 150
second periods of Lucidity every 24
hours the subjects would become
extremely distressed agitated and even
aggressive Dr Chung also ordered any
Idols from trash sculptures to Doodles
and notes on fragmented scraps of paper
to be destroyed immediately at its new
increased power the foundation became
concerned that scp-20
774-a May develop the power to manifest
through these images no meaningful
Headway was being made on a cure for the
condition so something needed to be done
before the situation got out of hand in
hopes of gaining a better understanding
of the internal processes of Slow Burn
sloth victims Dr Chung decided to
conduct a series of interviews with the
subjects under her care two such
subjects subject 0866 AKA David and
subject 7444 AKA Claire were isolated
for a 24-hour period in hopes of
catching them during their daily 150
seconds of Lucidity Dr Chung and the
foundation found the results of these
two interviews to be as Illuminating as
they were utterly terrifying when David
regained Lucidity he was in a state of
extreme agitation and showed an
unsettling fixation on the clock in the
site 116 interview room under direct
questioning from Dr Chung he revealed
that Slow Burn sloth victims are fully
aware of what's happening during their
zombified period kids he compared the
sensation to being a passenger trapped
and bound in a vehicle over which they
have no control however in this state
victims are also unable to hold a
thought consistently for longer than
five seconds this leaves them in an
almost constant state of disorientation
worse still David describes the victims
are subjected to near constant
hallucinations of the original sloth
image guiding and controlling their
movements almost like a puppeteer thanks
to the clock David was aware of when his
150 seconds of Lucidity were about to
come to an end after apologizing for
what he was about to do David lunged at
Dr Chung causing a guard present in the
interview room to shoot him dead for Dr
Chung's protection Dr Chung's interview
with Claire echoed the same sentiment
during her 150 seconds of Lucidity
Claire first begged to be killed before
divulging further details about the
zombification state she would describe
hallucinations of the Slow Burn sloths
stalking her constantly and can
controlling her movements in some cases
the sloth would force her to open her
eyes all night while it stands next to
her bed and screams at her as Claire's
150 seconds of Lucidity ended and she
became non-responsive Dr Chung put in a
request for Claire's termination a
request that was fulfilled three days
later the third interview with subject
9225 also known as Jason showed that
scp-2774-a appeared to be manually
starting the fights between the subjects
perhaps even for its own sadistic
Amusement he also stated before the
interview's conclusion that the image of
the sloth and his hallucinations was
becoming darker and more tangible almost
like it was becoming a real physical
being which was an unprecedented
phenomenon Dr Chung was for the first
time in a while truly afraid it seemed
by all accounts that
scp-2774-a's power was growing
considerably as a result of its huge
number of act victims its infection rate
had likely risen well above 40 percent
and its ability to manifest would likely
be on the rise too if the Slow Burn
sloth was able to manifest on a national
broadcast Millions would be infected to
truly apocalyptic results Dr Chung only
saw one solution that might curtail the
entity's growing power but it wouldn't
be pretty she devised a procedure known
as procedure xxj9 as part of the
procedure additional staff were brought
into site-116 immediately the real
purpose of the plan was revealed shortly
afterward to reduce the number of active
subjects on site from 6400 to a mere 200
in hopes of reducing risk over the next
several days staff at site 116 engaged
in the gruesome task of executing around
6 200 infected subjects via lethal
injection this was an atrocity so
horrific even by a CP Foundation
standards that Dr Chung allowed the
parties involved to use use class
amnestics to erase their memories of
being involved in the mass murder of
site 116 subjects in the aftermath of
the call the foundation did report a
decrease in
scp-2774-a's manifestations so Dr
Chung's procedure did indeed work just
at a heavy human toll the tragic
incident of the 2010 Harper Ridge
scp-2774 Containment Breach is a grim
reminder of just how far the SCP
Foundation is willing to go to do their
job and a reminder to be careful where
you look because some images have a much
more lasting impact than others the
foundation regularly deals with
anomalies of a more Sinister nature the
most frightening among these of course
are the ones that stalk and kill
foundation operatives for no clear Rhyme
or Reason sometimes the foundation's
agents and researchers become subject to
things that seek to entrap and utterly
consume them Dr Elizabeth Graham is once
such poor soul nowadays her name is
whispered through mess halls and
cubicles since no one really seems to
know what happened to her one moment she
was carrying a stack of files between
two offices the next completely gone the
foundation security teams couldn't
figure out what happened to her the CCTV
cameras just showed her blinking out of
existence and the files falling to the
floor her biometric scanners simply
returned a dead signal it seemed that
one day Dr Graham simply ceased to exist
of course the foundation isn't above
keeping secrets from its own Personnel
perhaps they did find something a series
of SCP documents covered in sand
suddenly appearing in Graham's office
one day neatly stacked and paper clipped
all signed by her in her own handwriting
and detailing her days spent in a pocket
reality of some sort it wouldn't be the
first time it had happened the infamous
red reality incident with Dr Robert
Scranton had already upset researchers
and there was no reason to alarm them
further about something they couldn't
change so Dr Graham's papers were
covered up and relegated to long-term
storage where they would likely never be
thought of again but don't you wonder
what happened to Dr Graham the first
thing Dr Graham felt when she woke up
was confusion she didn't remember
falling asleep in fact she didn't
remember much at all she had been moving
files between two offices at site-22 on
a normal work day she said hello to some
of her co-workers and had a late lunch
before returning to work and then
nothing the second thing she felt was
fear she looked around and realized she
was in some kind of desert a bright blue
sky was overhead and there seemed to be
a sun but all around her was sand
massive sand dunes flowing sand Plains
and even what looked like a sandstorm in
the distance but all there was was sand
Dr Graham then noticed she was still
holding some things a small folder
filled with paper clip documents pulling
one out she realized what it was a
template document for an SCP file
complete with sections for object class
containment procedures and descriptions
this place was obviously not normal but
she had been anomalously transported to
it it needed to be documented there was
nothing else to do so she sat down and
began to write she guessed at a number
who knows what SCP the foundation was on
now might as well pick something for the
middle she scrawled
scp-3890 at the top and bubbled in
ketter for the object class the
containment procedures were Spartan but
effective no effective measures of
containment were possible and she would
focus on simply exploring and finding
out what was going on then came the
description no point in sticking to the
foundation's signature clinical tone
given the circumstances it was more
important to get the information down
and so she began to transfer describe
her thoughts
scp-3890 is a potentially extra
dimensional or extraterrestrial space
which I Dr Elizabeth Graham was somehow
transported to from site-22 on
21716. I'm uncertain as to whether I was
transported here due to my involvement
with the foundation after finishing the
paragraph she picked herself up off the
Sand Dune she had landed on and started
to walk in the direction of the sun she
didn't have much information and
exploring would be necessary if she was
to accurately document the anomaly it
didn't take long before she came across
something in the distance an old
collapsed Temple completely ruined from
the outside the structure sagging in on
itself it had the columns and facades of
a Roman building she noticed appearing
inside it was completely empty except
for more sand in the distance more runes
were present some older and some more
modern office looking buildings in terms
of geography scp-30 890 takes the form
of a seemingly infinite desert plane
with ruins of differing architectural
design poking out through the sand I've
noted the presence of buildings of
modern design along with what appear to
be ruins of ancient Roman and Ericsson
structures she only noticed the first
figure when the sun started to set as
the sky shifted to Twilight she saw a
person walking casting a long Shadow
excitedly she yelled out to no response
when she approached she saw a man in an
older suit with completely lifeless eyes
stumbling along
scp-3890-1 is my Collective designation
for the humanoid entities that wander
through
scp-3890 they did not respond to any
stimuli and as far as I've been able to
tell simply walk around without a
specific destination
scp-3890-1 are either entities that have
been created to resemble humans but
imperfect where they are humans who have
been mentally altered in some way to Rob
them of of their faculties there did
seem to be some kind of a day night
cycle and she didn't feel hungry or
thirsty at all though she did feel
sleepy after her first day in the desert
Dr Graham settled in one of the
collapsed ruins drifting off to sleep
the second document opens much
differently this appears to be a
document for something designated
scp-3890-2 ketter the containment
procedures are simply to always
constantly be on guard for it whatever
it is if Dr Graham feels something she
is approaching is not as it appears she
is to immediately Retreat the
description is a little clearer
scp-3890-2 is a living entity of varying
shape and size which resides in
scp-3890 I am uncertain as to whether
scp-3890-2 originates here or if it was
transported here at some point in the
same way I was from what I have observed
of Its Behavior it appears to be some
form of Predator
scp-3890-2 is currently hunting me I
first encountered The Entity shortly
after writing down my initial
observations of scp-3890 it snuck up
behind me while I was resting and got me
while I wasn't paying attention I was
knocked unconscious by its attack and
woke up several hours later during the
night it had attacked me several times
since that first encounter with several
hours between each attack she was caught
off guard by it last night she hadn't
noticed its presence it seemed to just
be another building in the far-off
Horizon when she sat down and pulled out
her pencil and paper again she'd started
to fill in some more information about
the humanoids they seemed to
continuously walk in circles around some
of the ruins though it was unclear to
her why or even whether they were aware
of what they were doing but when she
pulled her pencil out she heard the
buzzing in her head it was like TV
static initially soft and low but then
ramping up and quickly becoming
deafening stifling her ability to think
she looked up and she saw it for a
moment it retained its form as the
building in the Horizon but that quickly
changed he began to unfold on itself
completely black on the inside like a
dark paper crane continually folding and
unfolding stretching and compressing in
on itself by the time Dr Graham got to
her feet and ran away she began to
realize what it had done and quickly
scrawled it onto the paper
scp-3890-2 uses anesthetization as a
form of attack while it has not injured
me physically thus far I've lost all
memory of significant chunks of my
childhood and early adulthood I can no
longer recall which high school I went
to or what my first job was my current
hypothesis is that as an entity it feeds
upon memory at first Dr Graham avoided
buildings and stayed to the empty parts
of the desert while walking but when the
creature appeared again unfolding out of
what seemed to be a piece of paper it
became clear what it was a mimic in the
coming hours it would pretend to be a
star a human a fly even a patch of dirt
while trying to make graham come closer
enough to consume her mind the next
document opens an even more dire
circumstances the containment procedures
have shifted drastically containment now
focuses on making sure that the mimic
does not consume any memories that Dr
Graham cannot afford to lose she is to
write down all vital memories so she can
recall them if they do get destroyed and
watch for its presence in situations and
at all times she writes the document
while huddled in a vault and a bank
dropped into
scp-3890 since it offers a little
security from the creature but the
corpses of a family in the bank imply
something less hopeful they chose to die
by their own hand rather than let them
mimic get to them Graham plans to kill
anything that tries to enter the Vault
to ensure that the mimic doesn't get in
but has bigger problems I have lost all
memories regarding how I came to be
employed by the Foundation I know that I
am a foundation researcher with level 3
clearance but I simply cannot recall how
I came to be in this position many of
the SCP objects I worked with are also
missing from my memory I can tell there
is a hole there but I just don't know
what was there before her memories of
her own identity have been obliterated
who she is where she's from but the
foundation even is they have all been
taken by the mimic without fail it
manages to surprise her and consume an
important memory then dashing away as
she tries to figure out what got stolen
from her something small like her
favorite food or her childhood bedroom
or something foundational and
fundamental like her name and her sense
of self and avoiding it isn't an option
he can pretend to be any of the single
grains of sand in the boundless desert
and Graham came to the conclusion this
is an infinite dimension of sand serving
as a hunting grounds for the mimic of
course it could be be anything else too
a brick a window any of the buildings
any of the Mindless wandering people or
the clothes on Dr Graham's back any of
them could be the mimic and Graham
thought of that too it's why she hasn't
let go of her knife in days even though
it's dripping blood from examining the
corpses of the former victims of
scp-3890-2 even though she doesn't need
to eat or drink there is another concern
sleep the moment she falls asleep the
mimic will no doubt be upon her she
hastily scribbled down a little bit more
onto the paper before trying to rest the
sun's going down I can't allow myself to
fall asleep
3890-2 will come in without a doubt if I
do I don't have to eat I don't have to
drink but I still have to sleep this
place is designed for the mimics benefit
it can hunt its prey to its Hearts
content without them dying of thirst and
starvation is this an enclosure maybe
some kind of sick game my name is
Elizabeth Graham I can't forget that now
this page is my memory the next word she
writes on that paper shows something
ominous she can hear crying outside of
her makeshift shelter the next document
things have changed someone named Tony
is mentioned in the containment
procedures someone Graham trusts to take
watch while she sleeps and watches for
the mimic the descriptions explain Tony
is a child only 10 years old who fell
into this Dimension the same as Graham
when walking home from the playground
the mimic can imitate objects but it
can't speak the boy is real they've
worked on a rudimentary password system
to confirm each other's identities
regardless Graham feels almost hopeful
their chances of survival have doubled
even though they're being hunted not for
their lives but for the precious
memories inside their heads but she's
still worried about other things if
people don't starve or thirst to death
in scp-38 90 do they age how long have
the Mindless humanoids been wandering
around how long has she been wandering
around though she reminds herself of her
training she also faces the fact that
she might have been exclusively picked
for a past reason I have this memory
from my childhood still everything
around it is gone but it's sort of
floating free devoid of context I'm
visiting a woman in the hospital I I
think it's a hospital and I think it's a
woman I know a close relative my mother
or my grandmother I think and I go to
visit her I'm just a kid 12 I think and
she doesn't know who I am at all I don't
remember what happened before that or
after perhaps the mimic brought her here
because it knew she would hate having
her mind consumed like this but that
would mean it wasn't just intelligent
that it was sadistic and cruel she note
it down she'd asked Tony if he had a
similar experience and they'd be a
little closer to working it out the
document is hopeful Dr Graham now has
Something to Believe In the next
document is a complete mess scribblings
and squallings in the margins and the
text doesn't even begin to make any kind
of sense it's all word salad the ravings
of someone gone utterly insane she
mentions herself her own name repeatedly
and constantly but in between are
mentions of Tony the foundation the
mimic and everything in between Dr
Graham has lost her grip on reality that
or whatever wrote this wasn't Dr
Elizabeth Graham the document after that
has a very simple containment procedures
she is to kill
scp-3890-2 the mimic description I woke
up this morning Tony was gone he was the
mimic it was smarter than I thought I
guess I was stupid I should have seen
this coming but I was desperate and it
knew it all it left was some scrawled
documents in a hole in my head the shape
of my name the mimic disguising itself
as a child had still Island the last
thing she had left her name all of
Graham's precautions were useless even
though her name was written down a dozen
times in the last documentation she
cannot remember it in fact when she
reads it it immediately removes itself
from her mind again not only has it
taken her memory it has taken her
ability to reform them and the document
it left behind is one of her own an SCP
template though of course she doesn't
know what the foundation is anymore the
same document we have seen previously in
the pile yes the mimic is learning to
imitate Graham and getting better at it
maybe that's why she hasn't been killed
yet it's yet to pin down her thought
process and is waiting until it has her
perfectly memorized not that she would
know given that she's forgotten how she
even came here or when but the mimic
made a mistake it took everything from
her even her hope which has left Dr
Elizabeth Graham a woman with nothing
left to lose she resolves she will not
get out of
scp-3890 the documents will probably
wind back up in Foundation possession
from some testing with an unrelated
anomaly but she will be a Mindless husk
or worse she plans to kill the mimic
it's a cowardly fearful stalker creature
and only Hunts by pretending to be other
things she knows she can take it in a
fight and she still has her knife the
next document is sober the object class
neutralized Dr Graham walked boundlessly
through the desert until the mimic
jumped for her it unfolded from a cloud
turning into a massive black origami and
lunging for her it didn't expect her to
turn around and slash outward with her
knife piercing its strange black flesh
it let out a scream shrank and Dr Graham
realized that it could feel pain so when
it lunged again she drove her knife
deeper into it before pulling back and
she repeated the process until it was a
tiny black mite in the sand and then she
crushed it under her heel it was that
easy that simple but of course every
time it had come close to her it had
taken another bite out of her mind just
as she took another slash at its form we
opened each other up I filled its body
with holes and it filled my mind with
them there's not much left of me she
curses herself from not having done it
earlier but maybe there was a reason she
can't remember it anymore in any case
the mimics dying bites from her were
particularly damaging the straw that
broke the camel's back what's left of Dr
Elizabeth Graham is falling apart she
scribbles things down onto the paper
while her mind realizes that she can't
even understand what she's writing
anymore the next document is empty not
every story with the foundation's agents
fighting a monster has a happy ending
art as it has been said is often
subjective whether it's a sculpture an
oil painting from the Renaissance a
renowned work of literature A digitally
drawn webcomic or an insightful animated
YouTube video about SCP Foundation lore
the deeper meaning behind a piece of art
can often change depending on the
individual observing it sometimes an
artist intentionally makes the message
of their artwork clear hoping to have
its meaning be unmistakable to any and
all that might see it other times such a
meaning can be more ambiguous harder to
decipher without some serious thought
but either way art is an important way
that human beings interpret the world
around us it can be a reflection of
emotions experiences history and every
new creation is as legitimate a piece of
art as the last but even with that being
said there may be no piece of art that
is a better reflection of the world
around us than
scp-804 or to use its alternative title
the world without man as you might have
already guessed
scp-804 is an art installation or at the
very least is what's left of an art
installation the piece itself which was
unveiled in Alaska was created by a
group of artists known by the name
a Finnish phrase which translates to
dreams of a better world in English A
fitting highly appropriate name for a
group that created
scp-804 given the subject of the piece
All That Remains of the artwork itself
is a portion of a once larger statue
sculpted to resemble the shape of a
globe following extensive examination by
the SCP foundation's researchers this
globe has been determined to be most
likely a recreation of our very own
planet Earth originally this globe was a
large clear model of Earth that also
featured a number of smaller Globes and
video equipment inside of it it appears
then that this art installation may have
been intended to function as a projector
of sorts displaying varying images of
scenes from around the world these
images would have primarily Focus just
on deserted and run-down areas of human
society such as abandoned buildings and
decaying landmarks the art piece seems
to have depicted how even when we
reshape our world and build cities we
can damage the planet's fragile
ecosystem this is especially prevalent
when things we build are then later left
empty buildings rotting away structures
neglected to waste this mass destruction
of nature all in vain these images would
then have been contrasted with
projections that show parts of the
natural world that have yet to be
touched by human beings Serene beautiful
places like the corners of the Amazon
rainforest or the deepest stretches of
our oceans the message of the piece well
we can only speculate but it seems as if
it played a role in highlighting the
difference between the modern and
natural world so what could be so
important about one leftover piece of a
statue how about this when it was first
unveiled scp-804 was able to produce a a
massive destructive force one in which
plenty of people were present to witness
the foundation has uncovered a number of
documents about world without man from
the artist's website when they stepped
in to clear up what happened after
scp-804 was revealed among those present
when the piece was displayed were an
audience of prominent environmental
activists who were well known throughout
the world for their efforts to alert
people to the threats facing our
environment and would likely be the ones
that the message of world without man
would resonate with the most of course
we doubt that the SCP Foundation is all
that interested in the artistic value of
scp-804 or its message of protecting the
environment for that matter what
happened next was probably more likely
to be what caught their interest from
the moment it was activated
scp-804's destructive properties were
Unleashed and it is still unclear if
this was intentional or not had the
members of inel
matarashtamalash the plan to unfur chaos
at the revealing of their Masterpiece or
was world without man sabotaged by
someone who disagreed with its deeper
meaning it is hard to say the only thing
that the foundation knows for certain is
that no one survived anyone present
during the incident was killed where
they stood and those responsible for
creating
scp-804 either went into hiding or
perish themselves when activated the
smaller Globes within
scp-804's larger one began to rotate
causing the display of its destructive
and anomalous properties the sculpture
itself causes any man-made devices or
artifacts within a 100 meter radius to
stop working everything from phones and
tablets to clothing plastic buildings
and even synthetic chemical compounds
will begin to deteriorate Decay and even
disintegrate if something is more
advanced than a sharpened stick of wood
scp-804 can destroy it the longer world
without man remains active The Wider its
area of effect and the stronger its
destructive power will be however its
ability to destroy any man-made object
is always strongest closer to the source
right next to the globe of the sculpture
sounds pretty inconvenient to be
subjected to losing your clothes and
personal belongings if you stand too
close but still harmless right wrong
scp-804 also has an adverse destructive
effect on human beings tissue cells will
also deteriorate in the same way if they
are within the radius of world without
man however this happens much slower
than when the sculpture disintegrates
man-made matter people standing Too
Close will be painfully and
excruciatingly broken down cell by cell
a victim of scp-804 will gradually lose
body mass bit by bit until only their
skeleton remains but it does not stop
there the effects of the anomalous art
piece will continue even after death
dissolving bone organs muscle and Marrow
into their most basic Atomic components
until truly nothing remains
interestingly there are ways to survive
an encounter with the anomalous effects
of
scp-804 the first is to well not be a
human being anything non-human including
all forms of animal and plant life will
be left unharmed by the sculpture so if
you can somehow think of a quick way to
transform yourself into a bird or a
hydrangea you would manage to escape
unscathed in theory at least speaking of
escaping though even if you were caught
in scp-804's area of effect there is a
chance you could still survive if you
got far enough away before your entire
body was turned to dust though drastic
it is possible to recover from World
Without man's human tissue damage given
the proper circumstances and volume of
Medical Care during the CP foundation's
testing those who have survived have
suffered symptoms similar to those of
extreme and prolonged starvation
creating a sculpture that sends out a
shock wave capable of destroying all
man-made materials and any human beings
within 100 meters of its source is
certainly one hell of a way to get the
deeper message of your artwork across
but that might have you thinking if
scp-804 is a piece of art and it was
created by the members of an Art
Collective that isn't world without man
also technically man-made and you would
be correct in thinking that through
prolonged testing of the device the SCP
Foundation has determined that scp-804
is not immune to its own destructive
effects since its first activation and
over the course of the foundation's
rigorous examination of it the
sculpture's capabilities have become
impaired however this does not make it
any less dangerous if someone was
somehow how able to repair
scp-804 perhaps reunited with the Statue
it was originally a part of then the
threat it would pose to the modern world
would be astronomical how bad would the
damage be well let's put it this way if
scp-804 was able to remain fully active
without suffering its own effects then
this anomalous artwork could easily wipe
any and all traces of humanity from the
face of planet Earth in a matter of
weeks you could be forgiven for thinking
that destroying man-made artifacts and
disintegrating human tissue was the
worst that scp-804 can do but you would
be wrong yet again the foundation's top
researchers have theorized that world
without man also possess some form of
memetic effect that scp-804 is able to
mentally Influence People possibly
creating a compulsion among those who
view it however they are still uncertain
of this and testing is currently focused
on if this effect has also weakened by
scp-804's gradual Decay but back to when
this destructive piece of art was first
discovered
had unveiled world without man at an art
show in Alaska around five minutes after
scp-804 initially activated a nearby
remote town in northern Alaska was the
first to feel the effects the residents
were panicked calling for emergency
services after all wouldn't you be
afraid if you realize that you were
starting to disintegrate along with your
home and all of your possessions
unfortunately the town was too remote of
a location for anyone to properly
respond a single light aircraft was the
first on the scene and the pilot
witnessed firsthand as the entire town
was rapidly wiped out by the time the
foundation heard about the situation and
dispatched its agents to the location
there was nothing left not one home nor
any living person
scp-804 had been active for almost 8
straight hours and the nearby Alaskan
Town had been wiped clean of any and all
traces of human civilization the
foundation's agents traced the epicenter
of
scp-804's destructive effect back to
where it had been unveiled only to
discover that survivors from the nearby
Town had gathered around what was left
of the sculpture many of them were
already suffering from hypothermia as
well as being severely affected by the
device in other ways somehow these
survivors were being compelled to
approach
scp-804 and pushed the globe within to
reactivate its effect if one died
another would step forward from the
group to take their place those around
the sculpture would cheer and encourage
them to maintain the anomalous artwork
praising them for keeping it running
despite what scp-804 was doing to them
under the orders of an o5 council member
the foundation's agents on-site opened
fire on the crowd their bullets
disintegrating from the statue's effect
but still manage to cause lethal wounds
as the globe stopped spinning the
effects of scp-804 ended and the Agents
were able to move in and secure the
sculpture many of the survivors then
opted to lie down in the snow letting
their injuries and the cold kill them
any that were arrested by the foundation
refused to respond to questioning given
that any foundation facility would be
man-made in nature it was decided that
scp-804 would be best left where it was
allowing the Alaskan cold to freeze its
Machinery a handful of foundation guards
were left on site as well just in case
anyone decided to come looking for world
without man and try to reactivate the
anomalous piece of art additionally the
foundation wanted the remains of the
device kept away from their facilities
until they could figure out if or how it
had compelled people to keep it active
Dr Johannes swords of the SCP Foundation
investigated the memetic properties of
scp-804 and according to a findings
there is nothing especially virulent or
dangerous About
scp-804's metic Properties only a few
select personality types have any desire
to reactivate the device we've been
looking at this all wrong there is no
magical compulsion that could drive so
many people to destroy themselves there
does not need to be the artist and
activist group
had created a device capable of wiping
out all traces of human life on Earth it
could turn buildings and people to dust
making any that were left keeping it
spinning no matter if it killed them it
was made to represent an ideal the cure
for the planet from the disease of
humanity but why would these activists
unleash it on a town full of innocent
people if they knew this machine had the
potential to wipe out all human life on
Earth why activate it killing themselves
too the answer is simple because the
they wanted to they intended to send a
message but the real question is are we
smart enough to listen to it help me
help me with somebody
failed me I'm lost and I can't see it
echoed through the alley in a thin Reedy
voice that suggested brittleness of body
and spirit who wouldn't hear that cry
and feel a Pang of sympathy are you so
heartless that you'd ignore the
desperate pleas for help of a blind man
clearly in distress for all you know he
might even be in danger what if he walks
into a road and gets hit by a car would
you really want that on your conscience
questions like these were flying through
the head of the Good Samaritan when he
decided to go and investigate when it
seemed like everyone else was just
content to pretend they didn't hear it
and carry on with their day as normal
the Good Samaritan was a person not
unlike yourself they were also the kind
of person we all hoped and wished we
would be in a situation such as this
kindness and generosity is a virtue
after all the problem is there are
people out there who know this and are
willing to take advantage of that
kindness and generosity but even worse
is the fact that there are things that
are definitely not people out there
willing to take advantage of human
compassion too but back to the Good
Samaritan he approached the sound of the
distrust man in the alley he looked old
and frail hunched over with the weight
of his ears he wore thick dark glasses
and his white cane was laying on the
road a few feet away from him it was a
tragic scene but thankfully the Good
Samaritan was here to help he approached
the old man calmly telling him that it
would be okay the Good Samaritan picked
up the walking cane and passed it over
to the blind old man his face spread
into a warm smile and he said thank you
thank you thank you young man
it warms my heart to know there are
still good people like you on this Earth
the old man told the Good Samaritan that
he'd come into town to get some fresh
air and a little exercise at which point
he'd gotten lost when the Good Samaritan
asked whether it was safe for him to
come alone the old man told him that he
always used to go on walks with his wife
but ever since the accident she didn't
seem to want to be seen in public the
Good Samaritan naturally felt for the
old man who seemed as sweet as he was
feeble he offered to escort the old man
back to his house personally wanting to
make sure that he returned home safely
the old man smiled and graciously
accepted saying that his wife would
probably want to thank the kind young
man for helping him in person of course
the Good Samaritan was so wrapped up in
the warm glow of doing a good deed that
he never once stopped to question the
strangeness of this whole situation he
just walked along with the old man
listening to him tell his fanciful
stories as they left the city center and
crept further into the Sleepy outskirts
of their small Kentucky Town it was just
rambling on as old men tend to do he
told the Good Samaritan a little more
about his beloved wife she was a kind
woman who'd he'd known for as long as he
could remember his elementary school
sweetheart then his high school
girlfriend and not long after they
graduated his beautiful Blushing Bride
oh yes she'd always been the prettiest
lady until the accident curiosity was
getting the better of him the Good
Samaritan couldn't help but ask what
exactly the accident he kept alluding to
was and the old man was all too happy to
give him an answer not that this answer
was in any way Pleasant his wife had
been trapped in a terrible fire in town
that gave her severe burns all over her
body she was lucky to be alive but the
Flames took her beauty and her
confidence away from her since then
she'd become a real homebody often
refusing to leave the house and rarely
ever letting strangers see her the good
Samaritan's heart ached for this poor
old couple why were such nice people
often forced to endure so much suffering
did this old man even have anyone else
to talk to they reached his house soon
enough it was the furthest one on the
end of the street right next to the
darkness of the woods it looked old and
dilapidated but it wasn't like the old
blind man could even know that as they
were walking up the small set of stairs
to the porch the old man stumbled
slightly causing his thick dark glasses
to fall to the floor the Good Samaritan
reflexively leaned over to pick up the
glasses for the old man as he passed
them back he noticed something strange
the old man wasn't just blind he
literally didn't have any eyes just two
black empty sockets where his eyes
should be the Good Samaritan was just
thankful that the old man wasn't able to
see him staring as he put the glasses
back on the two of them entered the
house the Good Samaritan was too busy
thinking about the old man's empty eye
sockets to even notice him locking the
door behind them and by then then it was
already too late for him the old man
called out into the dark expanse of the
house sweetheart I've got your live
walk before the Good Samaritan could ask
what he actually meant by that the old
man shuffled off definitely navigating
the Halls through memory alone and took
one of the two seats at the dining table
he just sat there smiling waiting that's
when the Good Samaritan heard the
creaking sound coming from above
something moving up in the darkness of
the second floor and then descending the
stairs with heavy clumping footsteps
when his eyes came into focus in the
dark he saw it there the most terrifying
thing he'd ever witnessed coming down
the stairs towards him it was vaguely
human in its shape alone but in all
other respects it was a monster through
and through this gnarled Twisted
creature with bulging eyes dead flesh
and filthy exposed fangs like it stepped
straight out of a nightmare and into the
physical world where it did not belong
there looked to be a huge hole in its
lower torso too with no blood or organs
inside just an infinite blackness the
creature's lipless mouth Twisted into a
smile the creature said something in a
voice that the Good Samaritan couldn't
understand it was the black tongue
something ancient terrifying and unknown
as the creature got closer and closer
the Good Samaritan turned and made a run
for the door he tried to figure out the
lock his hands fumbling and
uncoordinated by fear he could hear the
footsteps and the heavy breathing of
that thing getting closer behind him he
was so close almost there that's when a
strange black substance seemed to encase
the world around him it separated him
from the door he was so nearly able to
breach locking him in he was trapped
inside what looked like a giant black
sphere made of some unknown material or
energy he turned to see that monster
standing right behind him just grinning
and waiting for the inevitability of
this situation to sink in the Good
Samaritan had never been more terrified
something else began to shift inside the
sphere her a structure was growing out
of the ground up and around him like a
cage within a cage he was trapped and
huddled inside a strange conical
structure as more figures entered the
sphere around him they were just like
the first this horrible horde of
desiccated knot people all with grinning
lipless mouths when they closed in on
him the Good Samaritan had the one
consolation that at least it was over
but it wasn't not yet the blind old man
waited in the kitchen for five hours as
unmentionable Horrors unfolded inside
the black sphere the Good Samaritan was
actually lucky all in all because for
some sessions for victims inside the
sphere had lasted as long as 27 hours he
screamed the entire time with a sphere
finally demanifesting just moments after
the screaming stopped remaining was only
one of the creatures but no Good
Samaritan just several neat piles of
human organs arranged by organ type I
are you down
in that old man asked I've been getting
awfully hungry the creature replied in
perfect English
[Applause]
the creature picked up some of the
discarded organs and took them into the
kitchen where it began cooking them into
a stew for the old man he ate the stew
not long after blissfully ignorant to
its contents and went to sleep whatever
organs from the Good Samaritan weren't
used in the stew were simply thrown into
the fireplace to burn away into ashes
later that night the old man would die
peacefully of a heart attack in his
sleep at age 81. he spent the latter 10
years of his life in service of
scp-957 he'd never even had a wife and
when the monster first invaded his home
he wasn't even blind he'd simply come
home one day to find scp-957 lurking in
his home waiting for him as far as the
SCP Foundation is aware it always
targets people who live alone the man
had tried to resist but the creature was
freakishly strong in spite of its wiry
frame it grabbed him and forced his body
into the dark gaping Chasm of its chest
he was swallowed up into another world
on the other side of the void and
returned four hours later a changed man
his eyes were gone and he now firmly
believed that scp-957 was his beloved if
burnt scarred wife of many years he'd do
anything for her even heading out into
the world and feigning distress to lure
people back into her terrible clutches
that's how the Old Man became
scp-957-1 he wasn't the first and
wouldn't be the last but the old man now
dead scp-957 would demanifest and head
off in search of a new victim invading
their home and repeating the cycle once
more somewhere else the somewhat happy
ending is that in one of these cases the
SCP Foundation somehow got wise to the
baiting activities of scp-957 and they
were able to contain the creature giving
it the ketter object class for its
frequent attempts to either get out or
lure in new victims it's never been
actively style to Foundation researchers
and guards just a little obtuse despite
the fact that it's perfectly capable of
speaking fluent English it prefers to
speak in an unknown dead language for
somewhat mysterious reasons very little
is known about the origins or true
nature of scp-957 but our brief glimpse
into its interior life does little to
comfort Us in 2008 the foundation
recorded 957 having a conversation with
an unseen individual in its native
tongue Foundation linguistic experts
have been able to partially crack the
code on what was being said that day 957
asked the Unseen figure how much longer
it would have to stay here the figure
told it that it would need to wait there
for a while and that its disguise was
extremely convincing 957 complained that
being here was boring and tiresome but
the Unseen figure urged 957 to remain
patient it said
soon enough
for as long as human beings have walked
upon the Earth and looked up to the
night sky at the vast Inky darkness of
space we've pondered a particular
question over and over again are we
truly alone in the universe surely it
can't just be us right the stars and
planets stretch out so vastly beyond the
confines of our little blue World it
seems that there's at least enough room
up there for some other forms of life to
exist but if they do if there is someone
or something out there would they be
Friend or Foe would an alien race be
sympathetic to the plights of humanity
or would they perhaps view us as a
hostile threat something to be wiped out
before we had a chance to do the same to
them how would such a race even go about
introducing itself to us with a swift
attack a grandiose emerging from space
or maybe they try something far subtler
a subterfuge observing Us From a
Distance watching learning all well
hidden in plain sight to answer these
questions posed throughout the ages the
ideas that have inspired generations of
Science Fiction writers perhaps we
should turn our gaze away from the Stars
let's start our story by instead looking
at something smaller something that
might be the exact opposite of the
incalculable vastness of space and all
the Mysteries it holds this story like
so many others begins not up there among
constellations meteors and gas giants
but in a small rural town a satellite
miles and miles away from the busy
lifestyle of the nearest city a place
where everyone knows each other's face
and where someone no something has been
waiting watching concealed in the one
place no one would expect now it's worth
remembering that when you live in a
small town being a local celebrity is
essentially just the same as infamy
saying that you're really famous in your
hometown can be like admitting that
you're considered the weirdest person in
your direct vicinity sometimes the
people with that mindset wind up
strutting around their Tiny Township in
the middle of nowhere under the
impression that their God's gift to
every passerby other times they Garner
odd looks and whispered stories from
anyone that spots them Gary knew more
than his fair share of these types he
worked at a small family-owned
convenience store one of those places
that everyone in town shopped at now as
any retail worker will tell you no one
who works in a shop ever really likes
their job ultimately it's usually just a
way to get paid with a promise of one
day being able to wave goodbye to the
cycle of stacking shelves and Manning
the cash register and so trapped in a
small town retail job usually stationed
in the one spot where he had to talk to
every customer that came through the
door Gary had seen them all from the
ordinary and boring to the nasty and
unreasonable but on the other side of
that list were the people who were just
a little bit off those customers might
look a bit Shady or
strange not enough to draw everyone's
attention but still enough to be noticed
almost like they felt uncomfortable in
their own skin one of the more Infamous
customers that Gary had encountered had
garnered one hell of a reputation with
his fellow employees they even had a
nickname for her The Duchess as those
working in the shop knew her she seemed
mostly oblivious to other people around
her until she needed something and her
way of asking for help was certainly
strange to say the least sometimes she
might be rude or talk without specifying
which of the store's employees she was
talking to but then there were the times
where she seemed to be trying to engage
in conversation with Gary or one of his
co-workers The Duchess might start out
speaking with most of her own patterns
but would seem to try to copy the
Cadence or dialect of whoever she
happened to be talking to she'd copy
accents Echo back particular phrases or
even other languages like she was
mocking them or trying to mimic them
naturally every time she appeared in the
store Gary and the rest of the staff ran
a mile or at least hid in the break room
out back until the owner of the store
told them to all get back to work but
among the employees caution was always
advised When approaching or providing
service to The Duchess as if she could
snap at a moment's notice whenever he
saw her Gary was reminded of his first
encounter with this particular customer
he had been unlucky enough to be filling
shelves when The Duchess had appeared
out of nowhere she forced a basket into
his hands and instructed Gary to follow
her around the shop and fill it with
items that she specified afterwards she
told them to carry her bags of shopping
outside and fill her car before she left
it was as though someone had altered
Gary's job description to Butler without
telling him no one fully understood why
she always acted so bizarrely there were
plenty of rumors circulating of course
ranging from the simple explanation of
she's from a different generation to the
more outlandish and wild theories while
he'd never fully believed in things like
that Gary always joked that she was so
disconnected because she was actually
from another planet sure an alien
disguised as a human coming to do their
grocery shopping at a Small Town store
sounds impossible right well maybe
around a week since his previous
Encounter With The Duchess Gary noticed
another customer in the store who seemed
to be acting just as unusually it was a
man this time wiry and Tall but hunched
over when the man had first come into
the store Gary had spotted him muttering
to himself instantly trapped once again
behind the cash register he felt his
heart drop immediately assuming the man
might cause trouble as he shuffled all
around the store slinking through the
aisles Gary could overhear him ranting
about waffles the wireframed man was
murmuring about waffles how they were a
pastry eaten for breakfast with syrup
how much humans enjoyed them humans he
hadn't said us he had specifically used
the word humans the man quickly
corrected himself with the proper word
almost as if he was teaching himself how
to speak naturally as anyone else
working retail would Gary assumed the
man was inebriated as was often the case
no matter how strange someone in the
store was acting the staff would
ultimately forget all about them by the
time their long eight-hour shift Drew to
a close and they were eventually allowed
to go home but maybe it was becoming
more frequent because for some reason
Gary couldn't help noticing even more
weird behavior from people all over town
sometimes it'd be somebody he knew a
neighbor a dog walker the one jogger
he'd see on their way back from the park
as he was heading home after work one
day they'd be themselves the next day
they'd be well alien every time he
spotted one it seemed that another would
appear the very next day little did Gary
know things were only due to get even
stranger still over the next month staff
from the store stopped showing up for
their shifts Gary's manager was in
pieces trying to call his employees to
find out exactly why they weren't
notifying him about their unscheduled
absence each one never gave a clear
answer the more of them stayed home the
longer Gary found himself having to pick
up the slack and cover their shifts at
first when it was just an extra one or
two shifts a week he didn't mind so much
working more hours meant extra pay but
as more and more of his colleagues
seemed to disappear Without a Trace Gary
started finding himself spending more
time at work than at home and feeling
pretty unhappy about it to say the least
after all what good is all that extra
overtime pay if you can't get any time
to spend it just as Gary's exhaustion
from having to work so much was reaching
its peak taking so much much of a toll
that he could barely stay awake at the
checkout that's when she appeared Again
The Duchess looked different this time
though and definitely not as the result
of a dramatic makeover immediately Gary
noticed some kind of growth swelling out
from the duchess's shoulder he didn't
want to stare that would be just as rude
if not worse than making a comment about
it but he was certain it hadn't been
there before on this particular day The
Duchess had seemingly also decided to be
more unreasonable than usual instead of
just making Gary carry her groceries out
to her car again she was insisting that
he bring them all the way back to her
house naturally Gary told her what any
reasonable person would explaining
calmly that he couldn't leave the store
during his shift in the interest of
putting his own safety first wrong move
the duchess didn't seem to understand
the concept repeatedly stating that this
was
non-negotiable now when someone in
Gary's line of work is faced with an
unreasonable and unusual request the
only person that can come to their aid
is their manager unfortunately a long
debate with the duchess was a battle
that Gary's boss just couldn't win
eventually after talking in circles with
the duchess the store owner folded
telling his employee to do as she asked
while he stayed behind and watched the
cash register begrudgingly Gary picked
up the duchess's groceries as she led
him out of the store big mistake
although it wasn't far and Gary wasn't
really listening the strange customers
seemed to be talking about a gathering
she was hosting with a group of local
townsfolk waiting at her home sure that
sounds normal enough for some small town
folk when there's limited number of
people who live near you loving Thy
Neighbor usually becomes your only
option for socializing but Gary wasn't
expecting the site that awaited him when
he arrived at the duchess's house just
as she had said there was a huge group
of locals there all of them Milling
around idly staring at Gary with wide
unnerving eyes not blinking as he
carried the groceries indoors as if that
wasn't strange enough almost all of them
seemed to be sporting the same type of
growth as The Duchess bulging out of
their shoulders or just visible under
shirt collars just like back in the
store Gary tried to force himself not to
stare never letting his eyes linger for
too long on one of the silent staring
townsfolk or their strange protrusions
but maybe he would have been safer if
he'd stared maybe he would have noticed
the group of them huddling around him
shuffling closer while his back was
turned if he stared he might have
spotted the hands reaching out towards
him and he might even have seen what
looked like his co-workers the friends
he had from the store all huddled at the
back of the room as far as his boss knew
Gary returned within a few minutes
followed shortly by the rest of his
staff the store owner spent a few
minutes angrily berating them for not
showing up to work on time not thinking
to question where they'd all been or why
they all came back to the store when
Gary did each of his employees simply
stood there staring at him hanging off
every word like it was the first time
they heard a human being speak or like
they were learning how to the truth was
neither Gary nor any of his colleagues
made it back to the store that day the
things that came back in their place
only looked like Gary and the others on
the outside just like the other people
in the town more and more of them had
been acting strange speaking in odd
patterns and sporting strange growths on
their bodies no one knows how long it
took for everyone to be replaced some
mysterious organization swept into town
a few weeks later a number of people or
the things that were disguised as people
all disappeared soon after any actual
humans that were left behind didn't
notice forgetting how many many others
used to live in the town as if they had
been drugged with the local store
closing its doors and fewer people
around most of them packed their
belongings and moved on heading to live
elsewhere eventually the town fell
silent if you were to pass through there
today you'd find nothing but the remains
of a community that gradually changed
into something alien all that's left of
the place now is a ghost town you might
even call it an empty shell few people
would ever really understand what
happened in that small rural Town even
those who did know would never admit to
it the SCP Foundation is like that as
you may well know they're shady
secretive and would much rather keep to
themselves not unlike that group of
townsfolk actually while that is after
they'd each been replaced by an instance
of
scp-3994 the thing no one dares to ask
about Humanity looking up to the stars
for so many centuries is what if someone
up there was looking back at us what if
for the entire lifetime of our
civilization there's been a race of
alien creatures attempting to study us
venturing to our Backwater small town of
a planet and taking the form of humans
for some nefarious purpose meet
scp-3994 that is if you haven't already
been acquainted with one of them they
could be anyone the local celebrity in
your small town a person who you pass on
the street every day even a wild animal
you see scp-3994 refers to a race of
extraterrestrials beings not of our
world and a currently unknown number of
them have been cataloged by the SCP
Foundation
scp-3994s tend to hide in plain sight
through the use of convincing human skin
disguises or shells well while these
shells might start by looking convincing
in actual fact they're far from perfect
almost 70 percent of SCP 3994 shells
experience some form of Rapid
degradation and this causes the
imperfections in their disguises to
shine through a deteriorating human
shell usually results in a number of
physical deformities an scp-3994
instance wearing its shell might appear
as someone with a limb that twists and
bends in an unnatural way but showing no
signs of actually noticing it
alternatively a person who seems to have
a skeleton that doesn't match their
external bodily proportions might also
be an extraterrestrial in hiding and
then there's the growths that some
scp-3994 shells have these are severe
malformations that resemble
elephantiasis a medical condition that
causes certain areas of the body to
enlarge but just looking out for these
towels isn't a Surefire way of spotting
one of these aliens not all their shells
have the same levels of decay in fact
the foundation has developed
subcategories of of scp-3994 instances
based on how noticeable their shells are
category a or
scp-3994s whose shells are almost
impossible to detect practically
resembling human beings one to one on
the other side are the category C's
which are members of the same
extraterrestrial species without shells
and between them in category B are the
ones whose shells are showing signs of
decay another method the SCP Foundation
has used to detect instances of scp-3994
is speech in almost 40 percent of
conversations these aliens will attempt
to mimic the speech patterns of the
human they are conversing with this can
be as blatant as
scp-3994's echoing back elements of
speech as hard to replicate as Regional
accents and dialects different languages
or specific phrases unique to the person
They're copying while in some instances
scp-3994s have shown difficulty with
grammar and syntax at first they seem to
be quick Learners couple that with
almost perfect shells in category a and
these alien visitors could prove to be
formidable infiltrators researchers even
discovered telepathic Communications
between instances eventually though all
scp-3994 shells do inevitably Decay this
usually takes around a year as their
human disguises gradually dissolve until
the creature beneath is eventually
exposed that's where the various
protrusions misshapen body parts and
other signs of Decay come from it's not
that
scp-3994s are intentionally walking
around with noticeable shells it's that
they can't prevent their shells from
eventually withering away until their
true self is put on display and what do
they look like under their disguises are
they tall slender gray-skinned beings
with long heads are they tiny little
green men piloting human-sized robot
suits could they even be bulbous
creatures of living calcium with huge
claws kept concealed and compressed in
skin suits with zippers hidden under
their hairlines well no to all of these
that'd be terribly cliche don't you
think beneath their rapidly decaying
shells is a viscous pulp-like substance
of formless and unquantifiable
composition without their disguises
scp-3994 have no regular shape no
skeleton or body structure underneath
each of them is just an indeterminate
mass that drags itself around aimlessly
so the one question that remains is why
why come to Earth why replicate and
replace innocent humans why spend so
much time trying to learn how to blend
in as part of a civilization like
Sinister imposters Among Us well the
ones in Foundation captivity seem to be
pretty eager to leave during multiple
incidents they have been known to create
shells that mimic the appearance of
security staff scientists and other
Foundation Personnel in order to
orchestrate their escape all the while
they've been showing themselves capable
of learning how to impersonate human
speech and mannerisms but what is it all
for the best answer is we don't know or
rather we don't know yet could they be
here to study Humanity do these
scp-3994s want to learn how to be more
like us for their own benefit think
about it if you had no shape no body if
you were just a formless mess wouldn't
you feel a little lonely
scp-3994s like humans might be social
animals the difference is we can hug
each other high-five each other Converse
form meaningful connections through
talking and touch it could be that's
where these extraterrestrial imposters
want why they decided to venture across
the Stars to live among us that'd be
nice right but then there's the other
explanation
scp-3994 are an alien Army hiding out on
Earth learning more and more about us
day by day the more they learn the
better they'll get at copying us walking
talking and acting no different from any
other human the foundation doesn't even
know just how many are out there soon
they could have perfectly mimicked every
language every culture every person on
Earth and what happens then what happens
when we all get replaced well at that
point the planet would no longer belong
to us it would be the new home for
scp-3994 it has been often said that dog
is man's best friend and obviously that
isn't just exclusive to men ask any pet
owner whether they own a dog cat rabbit
hamster or soul-sucking interdimensional
parasitic monster with too many
tentacles and they'll all tell you the
same your pet can be your best friend
they can give you the most unconditional
affectionate form of love possible and
as long as you treat your little buddy
right they'll be loyal to you for the
rest of your life and theirs it's not
uncommon for a pet to outlive their
owner especially if they belong to
someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some
although it is important to remember the
positives like how much happiness and
companionship that animal would have
brought an aging owner in their last
years of life even someone younger who
dies unexpectedly might have had their
quality of life infinitely improved by
owning a loving pet to make them smile
but on the other hand there's the
negative downside that now some pets
have to live on after a tragic death not
fully understanding where their beloved
owner went so often we hear stories of
dogs that waited for their Master to
come home only for them to never walk
through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the
opposite way and an owner loses their
pet the one silver lining is that we as
human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it
causes we know that eventually despite
how hard it can be to adjust to that
initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to
one day get better but what happens when
someone can't accept the death of their
beloved animal companion when the
unconditional love of the their pet is
suddenly missing from their life how far
will a person go to recapture that
feeling how long does it take for grief
born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of
obsession well the answer involves
scp-589 both what it can give and just
as easily take away for as long as she
could remember and even further back
than that Aaron and her dog Pancho had
been Inseparable ever since her mom had
first adopted that scrappy little Jack
Russell Terrier Aaron had fallen head
over heels in love with that little
rascal loving a pet is different from
loving another person because they just
can't help showing how much they love
you back humans for all their good
qualities are so nuanced and not
everyone is honest with each other all
of the time but a pet especially a dog
even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tail can
easily tell you how they're feeling and
Poncho was no exception Aaron and her
mom Cleo lived alone who was just the
two of them for quite a long time and
while Cleo had little problem with that
she couldn't help but notice how
isolating it was for her daughter from a
young age Aaron had always been quiet
kept to herself at school her mom kept
expecting her to make some friends asked
to invite them over or vice versa but it
didn't seem to be happening it didn't
seem to be bothering her daughter but
Cleo was worried that it was giving her
the wrong idea that being on her own was
somehow better so in an effort to give
Aaron at least one source of
companionship Pancho joined the family
brown patches dotted over his white fur
he was the perfect pet an excitable and
loving little puppy that Aaron was
immediately smitten with when Cleo told
her he was hers to keep being only seven
years old Aaron broke down crying with
tears of joy her mom had let her pick
out a name for him and she quickly
settled on Poncho at first Aaron had
meant to say it differently in order to
name the pup after a friendly character
from her favorite animated movie but had
mispronounced it in her excitement at
meeting the energetic dog for the first
time the name quickly stuck though and
as the years went on and Pancho got
bigger Aaron bought her four-legged best
friend a little Poncho of his own to
wear when it started raining over the
following years Pancho became Aaron's
most constant and loving companion even
as she grew up moving through her
childhood and found making friends a
little easier with every passing year
there never came a time when she didn't
need her best friend when Aaron had her
first breakup in high school and came
home with floods of Tears In Her Eyes
Pancho could sense she was upset and
came wandering up to her sitting in her
lap to make her feel just a little bit
better then a few years later when her
mom got sick Aaron had to take care of
her a task that would have been much
harder without Pancho there to alleviate
that dress and lift her and Cleo's
spirits and when Cleo eventually passed
the little white and brown dog sat
quietly with his owner as she said
goodbye to her mom now that it was just
the two of them Aaron and Pancho were
living in a tiny apartment it was
crammed for one person and a dog but
Aaron was just grateful to have a place
to live and the company of her favorite
pop besides Pancho wasn't a puppy
anymore in fact he hadn't raced around
the park or chased a ball for quite a
long time with the numerous stresses of
her everyday life least of all holding
down two jobs in her desperate attempts
to make enough money to pay rent Aaron
had hardly noticed the signs Pancho was
showing his age it had been happening
gradually in the background over the
years he wouldn't chase the ball or
really move around much and when he did
it was little more than a lethargic plot
around the apartment perhaps it was
because of such a measured slower Pace
change that Aaron was unable to
acknowledge it she could see her old
friend was getting more tired sleeping
longer his tail really wagging as much
as it used to but by now that felt like
Pancho's normal behavior then again
given how important her dog was to her
it's just as likely she didn't want to
accept the truth that unfortunately
nothing lasts forever he was almost 15
in human years which by all accounts is
an impressive age for a dog especially
one of Pancho's size and breed it was on
a day that Aaron was out working her
morning job when it happened the
faithful adoring Jack Russell Terrier
who had spent his years being nothing
but loved and giving back only more love
in return curled up on Aaron's bed the
apartment was still Silent not a sound
to be heard save for those last tired
few breaths laying there maybe the dog
wondered if he'd ever get to see his
friend again if she would make it back
from work in time he closed his little
brown eyes and peacefully drifted off
for one last sleep during the break
between her shifts after the end of the
one at her first job and before starting
her second Aaron had just enough time to
get home usually she had just had enough
time to eat and get herself ready for
the changeover then quickly check on
Pancho before having to dash back out
poking her head into the bedroom she saw
her dog laying right there on her bed
there was a Stillness to him that
instantly made her stomach drop his ears
didn't move when she called his name he
didn't react when she stroked his fur he
was gone and the moment she realized it
Aaron felt like her whole world had come
crashing down the loss of her oldest and
closest friend hurt almost as much as
losing her mom Aaron always felt that
the problem with funerals wasn't just
how sad they were or how it always
seemed to rain when she went to one
instead it was more that they could
never properly sum up just how much
someone truly meant nobody could ever
condense the year's worth of love and
memories into a burial and it was worse
when losing a pet there was no
procession no wake nobody else there
just her and Poncho saying goodbye a
final time eventually things got to be
too much the Heartbreak of Pancho's
death was another struggle in the
lifetime of lows that had all left their
lasting wounds on Aaron that coupled
with this stress of trying to carry on
with a busy life barely able to keep
herself afloat in either of her jobs had
pushed her to the edge of a breakdown
maybe that's what summoned it perhaps
something had sensed all of Aaron's
mental anguish and had come to seek her
out it might have been that her wishes
for something some little alleviation to
all the pain and stress were finally
being granted or maybe it was just a
gift left by her neighbor the sun had
long since set when Aaron arrived back
at her apartment stepping over the
envelopes that littered her doormat a
few with words like overdue and Urgent
notice printed on them in red ink
passing through the hallway Aaron paused
as she always did hoping to hear the
gentle pattern sharing of Paws against
the floor her therapist had dissuaded
her from doing that saying it would only
make moving on from losing Poncho worse
she didn't care she wanted her dog back
and opening the door to her bedroom it
seemed like someone had been listening
sat on her bed was a stuffed animal
right in the spot where she'd found her
little friend on that horrible day it
had been made to look like a dog
specifically resembling a Jack Russell
Terrier with brown patches over its
white fur the plushie was even wearing a
little rain poncho the side of it was
enough to cause Aaron to break down in
tears weeping in heavy sobs as she
dashed across the bedroom to hold it in
her arms hugging it tightly her tears
seeped into the soft fur as she felt it
against her face she didn't even think
to question where it had even come from
all she wanted to do in that moment was
hold the stuffed animal close for the
first time in what felt like years a
feeling of relief washed over Aaron it
was as if everything was melting
the stress of work and the toll of her
tiring shifts gone all the pain from
losing Cleo and Pancho dissipated too in
fact it felt like she now had her
beloved dog back now it was better than
that it was almost as though everything
about Poncho his energy his Spirit the
way he made her feel so calm and loved
was all distilled into this stuffed
animal and now it would never grow old
never age and die causing her more pain
Aaron gripped the soft toy tightly the
longer she held the hug for the more her
stress and sadness faded her face was
still wet with tears although her
sobbing had gradually become low gentle
Chuckles soon giving way to appeal of
uncontrollable laughter rising in volume
it was as though she had taken something
and the Very chemistry of her brain was
being altered but after so much hardship
it felt good to the point where she was
almost lightheaded laying down on the
floor of her bedroom arms locked around
the plushie that reminded her so much of
Poncho Aaron continued softly giggling
to herself her entire body relaxed so
much so that every part of her felt like
warm butter as if she was about to start
melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't
have even cared her dopamine levels were
spiking flooding her with the bodily
hormone that relieves stress and makes a
person feel good in fact right now she
was feeling better than she ever had
every day that followed Aaron would come
home to our stuffed animal her Poncho
too as she'd like to think of it it
didn't bother her how childlike anyone
else might find it for a grown woman to
rely so heavily on a plushie for Comfort
at any rate it wasn't something she was
advertising to anyone else after every
shift at both of her jobs she'd race
back to her apartment right to Poncho
too and just sit there just basking in
the way it made her feel it was the most
all-encompassing sense of euphoria and
relief reducing her stress so much that
she felt like she was floating her body
lighter than air that feeling was all
that mattered to her some days she
wouldn't even eat Poncho 2 was more
important to her than food gradually she
started to become addicted to that
feeling having to wait until the end of
her work shifts to feel that Rush of
happy chemicals flood her brain was too
long of a delay she started to Crave it
while working unable to focus feeling
erratic and Restless without Poncho 2.
of course she couldn't risk bringing it
to work with her what if someone took it
or she dropped it her boss might see her
with a stuffed animal at her desk and
fire her on the spot or think that she
was absolutely crazy the only safe place
for her source of relief was at home but
Aaron knew she needed something to
bridge the gap while she was working the
only substitute that worked was taking a
photo of Pancho 2 on her phone then
blowing it up and printing off a copy
Aaron could carry it around portably
keeping it in her pocket and taking it
out to look at it every few minutes
while she worked the head of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as
strong as getting to hold her stuffed
animal after all it was just a grainy
photo from her phone essentially acting
like a patch to tighter over until she
could get back home to the real thing
however it didn't take long for Aaron to
start taking Pancho with her anywhere
that wasn't work to the grocery store to
visit her mom and her dog and of course
to therapy I'm rather concerned about
this pattern of behavior Aaron's
psychotherapist Dr Lee stated when her
patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite
side of her office on a leather couch
Aaron had Poncho 2 pressed tightly
against her I don't care she sighed her
brain already Awash with hormones that
kept her calm I like how it makes me
feel so I don't care Aaron look at
yourself Dr Lee urged you aren't
properly dealing with your grief it
seems to me you're channeling all your
desire for positive emotion into this
stuffed animal poncho two Aaron
corrected her without taking her eyes
off the soft brown and white dog in its
little cloak listen to me the therapist
insisted trying desperately to get
through to her Poncho you dog your real
dog is gone you lost him six months ago
and your mom Cleo she passed away too
you have to process and come to terms
with those things as sad as they might
make you feel that's how we move on but
what you're doing right now isn't
healthy Aaron it's becoming an obsession
Turning Away Aaron press Poncho 2 up
against her face I don't care she
repeated by now Aaron had become fully
dependent on Pancho 2 showing up late
for both jobs just so she could spend
longer feeling those endorphins and
hormones that hugging the stuffed
animals seem to bring it didn't take
long for her to start skipping entire
shifts for days at a time and canceling
any and all other plans just to sit at
home basking in the relief brought on by
her apparent Obsession her apartment
became a mess untidy piles of mail by
the front door the walls plastered with
hundreds of photos of her stuffed animal
fueling her Obsession her evening job
was the first to fire Aaron citing her
recent absences as the grounds for her
dismissal even then she still didn't
seem to care the fact she might not be
able to make rent barely registered
returning home after her other job
called her in to tell Aaron she would no
longer be working there either she
instantly looked around for Poncho too
but it was nowhere to be found all the
photos on the walls having faded Aaron
checked her phone all the original
copies of the pictures were gone too
instantly racked with fear so addicted
to the plushie that she could barely
function without it she began tearing
her apartment to shreds looking for it
she wrenched cupboards off their hinges
and tipped over her refrigerator
flipping her mattress Aaron sliced the
fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for Poncho too
but I'm able to find it anywhere she
became frantic erratic pulling her hair
out in a fit of uncontrollable despair
where had it gone had someone stolen it
Dr Lee the paranoia had already set in
convincing Aaron that her therapist must
have taken Poncho too she was the only
other person who knew about it and had
been so critical of her using it to make
herself feel better marching into Dr
Lee's office utterly enraged Beyond
Reason all Aaron could think about was
getting her stuffed animal back no
matter what she had to do the effect it
had on her was so powerful so potent and
addictive that living without it was
worth anything even another person's
life
little did Aaron realize as her hands
grew wetter coated with more of Dr Lee's
blood after every bludgeoning strike her
therapist had no idea where Pancho 2 was
in fact she had nothing to do with it
Vanishing in the first place it had
disappeared all on its own along with
all the photograph copies Aaron had
printed arriving somewhere miles away
scp-589 was ready to begin the whole
cycle again on its next victim it would
take on whatever shape it needed to
appease the desires of the very next
person to find it preying on their
vulnerability and making them totally
dependent on it that was what it did
everywhere it went leeching off people
that it could easily manipulate its
presence and interaction would calm
scp-589's victims helping to alleviate
their stress or make them feel better
about their deepest insecurities before
long these helpless victims would be
able to think of nothing else feeling as
if they were unable to live without
their obs session doll and every time
that was when scp-589 would make its
cruelest move it would vanish leaving
its prey in a state of intense
withdrawal with a calming influence of
scp-589 absent from their lives all of a
sudden the infected people would suffer
from a variety of potential
psychological symptoms manic depression
psychosis uncontrollable despair
Dementia or an errands case paranoia and
a heightened sense of aggression that
caused her to murder Dr Lee that was one
of the earliest in a Spate of similar
incidents that had been reported as
scp-589 traveled from town to town its
influence spread leaving entire
populations dead in its wake all the
while the stuffed animal fed on the
mental anguish that it caused its
victims making them pay the ultimate
price for their Obsession violent chaos
unfolds across the shoreline huge fleshy
tendril Slither out of the water
grabbing people who try to flee and drag
them into the depths as giant harpoons
made of bone whiz across the beach
cutting down unfortunate sunbathers and
troves it is a terrifying Massacre but
you'd never in a million years be able
to guess its source on April 10th 2010
something strange began to happen in the
three Portlands now the anomalous
extra-dimensional city-state that
overlaps with the locations of Portland
Oregon Portland Maine and the Isle of
Portland is no stranger to unusual
occurrences so it took the population a
little while to notice that something
was happening but for some unknown
reason sailboats and motorboats were
beginning to vanish from the city the
disappearances occurred overnight when
there was no one around to witness them
but slowly the citizens began to notice
that their friends and family members
were going out in their watercrafts and
never returning home by April 15th the
civilians were becoming noticeably
concerned fearing the worst on April
16th their worst fears were confirmed
when two local ghosts
and Greg Moore went for a nighttime
stroll along the harbor they heard a
sudden commotion and rushed to the scene
of the disturbance they arrived just in
time to see a living individual being
dragged into the watery depths by a
large vein-like tendril Ahmed asked Greg
to wait on land while he ventured out
into the water to look for the victim
unfortunately Ahmed never came back and
Greg took his story to the three
Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local
man-eating clam populace to migrate the
FBI unusual incidence unit mounted a
formal investigation on the morning of
April 17th all the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
what not been returned along along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been preying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11 19 a.m 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing veiny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous bow
but they were too slow to evade the
attacks and the boats snatched them off
of the shore and yanked them aboard
using their harpoons to impale those who
managed to run farther than the tendrils
could stretch as the army of fleshy
boats closed in around the shore a
tugboat broke through the surface of the
water unlike the rest of the boats it
had a noticeable hole in its Hull and
was missing its wheelhouse at an
unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat began
to advance onto land using its tendrils
to drag itself along the shore and into
the more populous part of town it
grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert izat
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach izat a city security Golem
interfered sadly though the gollum put
up a valiant fight the anomaly was able
to destroy it by Falling onto it again
in a again until the Golem was no longer
able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Golem
was not one of them with the Golem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the gruel was in the middle of
a busy brunch service at the site of the
invading watercraft the gruels set down
his picture of bottomless mimosas wiped
his hands on his apron and grabbed his
trusty dual-wheeled swords from
underneath the counter he kept them
there in case someone attempted to dine
and dash but he figured they would do
just fine against a blood-drinking
tugboat while the gruel kept the tugboat
busy uiu forces were able to break
through the barricade of boats for a
brief period of time allowing more
security Golems to enter the area as
well as allowing more citizens to escape
unfortunately this little victory was
short-lived as further unforeseen
Horrors dredged themselves up from the
deep the reanimated corpses of various
species native to the harbor began to
crawl out of the water surrounding the
gruel and allowing the tugboat to escape
the fight as it made its way back to the
harbor every boat it passed attempted to
toss bodies onto the tugboat covering it
in fresh blood slowly but surely the
damage to the tugboat began to repair
itself once the boat had regained its
strength it set its sights on a
previously untouched cargo ship and
observing uiu officer determined that
the boat was somehow attempting to
convert the cargo ship to transform it
into another one of its fleshy allies
but before the transformation could take
place a cargo crate broke open spilling
over 1 000 hardtack crackers suddenly
the tugboat stopped everything that it
was doing it took one tendril and began
to count each individual cracker that
had Spilled Out while the tugboat was
distracted with its task a citizen
offered the uiu use of their rare Metals
Cannonball collection in the fight to
apprehend the aggressive boat one
particular Cannonball made from electrum
was able to puncture the whole of one of
the infected ships rendering it
motionless they were elated to have
found a weapon that worked against these
boats while the tugboat continued to
count the remaining townspeople gathered
all of the electrum they could find and
began to fight back against the boats
One By One The Boat sank and all the
while the tugboat continued to count in
the meantime uiu officers managed to
free the gruel from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the gruel had a score
to settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the girl barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the Tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the
girl then threw the tugboat out of the
water and continued The Savage beating
before preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat careened through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the Isle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the gruel and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of
scp-6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat
scp-6426 is a cutter-class Sapient
hostile entity that in an inactive State
Bears the appearance of a harbor Tugboat
in a constant state of rust and
degradation any blood or organs
containing blood that come into contact
with the boat will be absorbed through
the metal causing the degradation to
visibly improve as a result the most
effective blood appears to come from
humans sedations and a few specific
species of solutions The Entity does not
only use the absorbed blood to improve
its appearance but is also capable of
using it to create organic additions to
its body including the vein-like
tendrils spotted in the three Portlands
Cognito hazardous eyes attached to
bending eye stalks Harpoon guns and
cannons capable of firing ammunition
made from anomalous species of barnacles
these Barnacles are capable of
reanimating dead tissue on contact and
scp-6426 frequently uses them to create
instant chances of
scp-6426-c masses of reanimated tissue
that the boat uses to Aid in its attacks
or self-defense
scp-6426 uses its tendrils to grab prey
and drag them towards itself but the
tendrils serve an additional purpose as
well each of the tendrils has a mouth on
the tip similar in structure to that of
the North American medicinal leech when
the tendril has made contact with its
prey the mouth will then bite into the
spinal column of the creature causing
its brain function to cease as its
canines grow long and Hollow hard scales
form on their skin and their muscle mass
and bone density increase once they've
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by a cp6426 are designated
scp-6426-a these instances are used to
the entity's advantage helping it to
extract blood from victims at a distance
as well as providing an additional line
of defense and offense in in the event
that
scp-6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use as
cp6426-a to convert the vehicle into an
instance of
scp-6426-b these converted boats are
similar to
scp-6426 and are able to function on
their own however they are unable to
produce their own eye stocks or cannons
unable to create
scp-6426-a instances and do not appear
to be as intelligent as their creator in
the early days of its containment the
exact nature of the anomaly's
intelligence was the subject of debate
amongst the research staff however on
one specific occasion the foundation was
able to establish a line of direct
communication with
scp-6426 and conduct the first and so
far the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied light
freed from the bounds of counting it
managed to escape and grab hold of
several Foundation staff members with
its tendrils after Chasing the boat
through the site guards were able to
Corner it prompting the boat to absorb
the bodies it had taken and used the
organic material to produce a siren that
emitted the sound of a human voice it is
through this siren that
scp-6426 responded to interview
questions using the voice of one of its
victims Junior researcher sajad
Williamson in spite of his protests was
selected to conduct the interview his
fellow staff members refused to take no
for an answer and as the newest higher
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
the self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I a fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch sharks selections yes
right
how rude of me is Dr Williamson's first
question concerned
scp-6426 apparent intended victim back
in three Portlands Albert is at
scp-6426 responded his first name is
really Albert
well what other relationship is there to
say besides the Hunter and the hunted
Admiral izat is a ruthless Man known for
terrorizing and slaughtering people like
me he was leading a search party of
those barbaric notophiles intending to
gut me like a seal what do you mean
people like you Dr Williamson inquired
free thinkers of course people who are
unafraid to break from the mold to carve
their own path in life instead of
following the predetermined route set by
that ignorant check valve the church is
built upon the foundation of lies no
one's really a petty officer on this
ship would all just cabin boys stumbling
around in the dark as we follow the
commands of an off-hand copy
if you want real power real Freedom all
you have to do is listen for the call of
the Beast open the porthole and he'll
squeeze you right through
Dr Williamson feeling rather in over his
head attempted to convince one of his
colleagues to take over when he refused
however Dr Williamson continued ah could
you explicate your activities within the
harbor and how you arrive there well
after I got the boat swans off my trail
I found a cave to hide him I was forced
to hide them yes forced to hide deep in
the cave which turned out to be a tunnel
surprisingly the tunnel led to some
Coastal Community where I took Refuge
licking my wounds in the safety of the
depths as ozelot stuck this surface I
spent my time preparing Gathering the
strength necessary to face them once
more until I was ambushed assaulted
Within
I fought for my life as I was forced out
into the open and descended upon by a
manner of monsters and freaks of this
orchestrated by that's coming back ESAT
I was beaten within an inch of my life
before I'm not quite sure what happened
after that I believe I was knocked
unconscious you'll have to Illuminate Me
on how I came to be in your custody at
this point the interview began to Veer
in an odd Direction the boat expressed
confusion about the nature of
Williamson's questions specifically how
little they related to the subject of
sharks and punching them it was at this
point that the site director sought
guidance from the multi-u Department a
researcher there informed Williamson
about the confusion
scp-6426 had mistaken the SCP Foundation
for another organization the shark
punching Center Dr Williamson resumed
the interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and contain
I mean Solutions this verbal misstep
caused scp-6426 to become suspicious
after a moment it pieced together the
truth and began to throw itself against
the wall in a desperate attempt to
escape it was apprehended by security
guards who impaled it with a naval RAM
and returned the watercraft to its
containment cell the exact reason for
its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently
scp-6426 is kept in a 39 meter by 39
meter by 50 meter containment chamber
beneath the chamber there is an
artificial lava tube the tugboat has a
naval Ram through its Hull and engine
holding it in place this Ram is checked
daily for signs of degradation as it is
the primary force keeping the anomaly
immobile if the ram is ever removed or
damaged somehow a Fail-Safe system will
activate releasing 100 hardtack crackers
and two pieces of electrum into the
containment chamber this is intended to
keep the tugboat occupied until the
naval Rod can be replaced if for some
reason the naval Rod fails and the boat
runs out of hardtack to count while
there will be nowhere on water or land
that we can hide
rock paper scissors a simple hand game
dating back to the Han Dynasty of
Imperial China it is a decisive game
between two players with the only
outcomes being Win Lose or Draw we're
quite familiar with rock paper scissors
here at the SCP Foundation as the guards
are often seen playing intense rounds of
the game to determine who will be the
Unlucky Soul chosen to secure one of the
various ketter class as CPS during a
given week in most cases this use of
rock paper scissors is accepted as a
largely harmless and Fair Way for
defensive Personnel to arrange their
chefs the reason for this is that the
results of rock paper scissors are
generally random as there are very few
ways for an individual's skill to
influence the game or so one might think
in reality rock paper scissors is a
deeply psychological game and this is
mainly because of its origin as a
contest between fellow human beings the
average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns and
with only three options to keep track of
it is entirely possible for a seasoned
veteran of rock paper scissors to
predict their opponent's Choice before
any hands are thrown of course that
opponent may also commit an error of
their own by misreading the other
player's actions and thus there is
always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the
game in either direction human
limitation is the only skill based
mechanic in the game of rock paper
scissors and that same limitation is
what in the eyes of some holds the game
back from reaching its true potential
that was the case until someone out
there discovered the rules to an
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
being spread through a mysterious email
while all attempts to trace the email
back to its original sender have left
the foundation with more questions than
answers we have been able to learn more
about the differences between the rules
of standard rock paper scissors and the
anomalous version we have given this
anomalous version version of rock paper
scissors the designation
scp-4633 and unlike the classic edition
under no circumstances are any
foundation Personnel allowed to play a
game incorporating any of the
alternative rules while the ceiling for
skill and variety is theoretically much
higher in a rock paper scissors match
featuring
scp-4633 the risks to the player far
outweigh any added novelty here is how
scp-4633 functions during an average
game of rock paper scissors well average
prior to the anomalous properties taking
effect rather than being limited to
using merely rock paper or scissors as
the name of the game implies the players
gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures which upon the act of
being thrown becomes seamlessly
integrated into both players shared
understanding of the rules this alone
would be bizarre enough but the true
harm caused by scp-4633 is in the nature
of the gestures themselves when one of
the non-standard gestures Allowed by
scp-4633 is used the player's hands will
change shape in ways that under normal
circumstances would be anatomically
impossible each of these non-standard
gestures is distinct from the rest with
the only commonality being an unusual
tendency for the final gesture to
resemble biological structures often
seen in sea life one particular gesture
might cause a player to rapidly grow a
ring of additional fingers surrounding a
gaping anemone like mouth in the Palm
while another could result in the
player's entire arm flattening into a
fin-like appendage regardless of how
severe a departure from a typical human
limb the final gesture would be the
limbs and on rare occasions the entire
body of the player using the gesture
will quickly end irreversibly mutate
into the shape required to successfully
perform it while these gestures
overwhelmingly result in forms that
would be distressing to most people the
same cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the
rules also appears to apply to the
changes affecting their own bodies to
the players of an scp-4633 augmented
match of rock paper scissors the
non-standard gestures seem as mundane as
the original Three unfortunately the
morphic properties of scp-4633 are
practically irreversible with extreme
reconstructive surgery being required
and even the best of cases in all
instances of
scp-4633 surgical intervention is
necessary to prevent the spread of
details regarding the non-standard
gestures and their usage because of the
immediate shift in cognitive awareness
among participants all that is needed
for a new instance of scp-4633 to occur
is the faintest hint of knowledge of the
alternative rules it's even been noted
that between different groups of players
the non-standard gestures can vary
heavily or seemingly be created on the
fly as the desire to win at all costs
takes hold here are a few examples of
anomalous gestures which have been
observed during instances of
scp-4633 this list is by no means
comprehensive but it will provide an
insight into how scp-4633 drastically
Alters the existing mechanics of the
game as well as the physique of the
players the Thor Riley gesture
transforms the user's fingers into
Barbed tentacles it beats paper and
scissors but loses to rock chavoga folds
the fingers of the hand into the palm
and causes them to emerge through the
back of the Palm it allows the user to
throw a second gesture after they've
seen their opponent's Choice ashkelhas
splits the hand into a pair of poisonous
Stingers which also produce a potent
electrical current between them it has
been seen to lose to paper but seemingly
of their own will The Stingers lashed at
the opposing player and caused them to
fall unconscious three rounds later due
to the effects of the poison
beats paper and two other anomal us
gestures loses to scissors rock and a
third gesture and morphs the user's arm
into a Dactyl Club similar to the front
appendage of a mantis shrimp the zergov
simply causes the player to grow three
additional thumbs on one hand the final
gesture resembles a triple thumbs up his
urogav has not been seen to beat any
gestures and the player who uses it
always seems to go on to lose the match
pagakumar causes the middle and ring to
recede into the hand while the pointer
and pinky fingers extend to resemble the
eye stalks of a snail or slug the rest
of the hand also becomes coated in a
thin layer of slime which continues to
secrete from within pagakmar beats
scissors and paper but loses to Rock and
Another anomalous gesture known as
vayanjic incidentally rajanjak causes
the arm of the player using it to
elongate into a worm-like tube that
periodically spews a gout of salt water
on the opponent when vyanchek was seen
beating pagakmar the saltwater appeared
to have some adverse effect on the
ladder gesture causing the eye stocks to
droop and the hand to shrivel until it
was half its original size another
anomalous gesture is grazothrog
recognized by the skin muscle and veins
of the hand turning translucent
revealing a pulsing red organ in the
interior of the Palm once grazatharag
has been thrown the player who used it
may call out the name of one other
gesture which can no longer be used in
the current match the ukayak gesture is
a bit deceptive as it resembles Rock
when first thrown but gradually causes
the hand to condense into a lump of
inert material not dissimilar to actual
igneous rock the knuckles as well begin
to exude a superheated mineral substance
similar to molten lava ukayog
exclusively beats paper and appears to
lose to everything else many of the
gestures on record have no known name
but their function within
scp-4633's altered rules is clear from
the context in which they were used such
is the case with one anomalous gesture
which caused most of the player's hand
to withdraw into a siphon-like opening
at their wrist before the very same
orifice shot out a stream of ink into
the opposing player's eyes while there
was no lasting harm done to the opponent
by this gesture the ink did cause
temporary blindness which persisted
until they were defeated by way of their
Rock losing to paper another unknown
gesture has been seen beating both
izorogov and ukayag this gesture makes
the player's hand resemble the crest and
gas-filled body of a Pacific Mana War
these examples are only scraping the
surface of the seemingly Endless
Possibilities that scp-4633 has to offer
as you can see the anomalous hand
gestures can be just as dangerous within
the game itself as the permanent changes
they invoke in the user while the
foundation has done its best to contain
all information surrounding
scp-4633 there have been clear efforts
by several unknown groups to push the
game into continued usage over the past
three decades in instances of scp-4633
have seen increasing popularity in the
world of high-stakes gambling Perhaps it
is because of the inherent thrill of
watching two opponents trying to
strategically outwit each other with a
countless number of non-standard
gestures but more likely it is part of
the anomalous effect of
scp-4633 that the game would appeal to
those desperate to risk everything on
the slim chance of Victory this neatly
brings us to the scp-4633 related
incident which occurred aboard the
private ocean liner known as the SS
fateful Emma before the incident the
Fateful Emma would sail into
international waters twice a year each
time it would bring along a new group of
passengers seemingly selected from the
underprivileged and downcast sector of
society a great many of these passengers
were convicts with repeat violent
offenses chosen from supermax facilities
the world over the process by which
these inmates were chosen for a voyage
aboard the ship was not dissimilar from
the methods the the foundation uses to
acquire new class D Personnel naturally
this was how the research team was able
to be tipped off about the Fateful Emma
it became apparent soon after looking
into the ship's career that the
individuals altered by the effects of
scp-4633 had been seen departing from
the ship on multiple occasions in remote
island Harbors most of the time the
individuals would also be to the best of
their ability with their metamorphized
forms carrying briefcases filled with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
while Witnesses tend to write off the
strange appearances of those affected as
being the result of a deformity or
injury or more pronounced instances
dismissing the encounters as sightings
of creatures from the local mythology
who was clear to anyone familiar with
scp-4633 what was truly going on these
passengers were being made to play
pitched games of rock paper scissors
featuring
scp-4633 for massive sums of wealth and
what was worse the grand prize winners
were seemingly being released back into
civilization without the knowledge of
law enforcement of course what the
foundation was most concerned about was
the potential for the large-scale leak
of detailed information involving
scp-4633 it seemed that the foundation's
latest faceless enemy had revealed
itself whatever wealthy group of
individuals was pulling the strings
behind the games aboard the SS fateful
Emma it was very likely that the ship
was also well protected by a private
Army of trained mercenaries in a display
of Swift but necessary initiative the
foundation assembled a brand new mobile
task force to be dispatched onto the
ocean liner mobile task force row 52
with the fitting code name Rochambeau
the mobile task force would board The
Vessel secretly and use whatever means
necessary to prevent the spread of
scp-4633 and any evidence of the
associated non-standard hand gestures
before the Fateful Emma's next Voyage
the foundation isolated the poor Port
where it would depart from and made sure
that the MTF agents were in position the
operation was co-captained by agent
DuBois and agent Shang both of whom
prided themselves on having
extraordinarily good luck agent Dubois
would stealthily move the majority of
the agents under his command into the
cargo hold below deck and await agent
Zhang's signal agent Zhang himself would
assume the name and identity of one of
the criminal passengers who was
intercepted before boarding by the
mobile task force the would-be
participant was subsequently detained
and brought into the foundation as a
Class D personnel as the SS fateful Emma
began to leave the harbor agent Zhang
joined the other passengers who had been
gathered together in an enormous
function hall there was little
indication of when the games would begin
and Zhang made an effort to keep a low
profile until more information was
available shortly after the ship had
officially arrived in international
waters an eccentric man entered the room
on a walkway that overlooked the rest of
the passengers he was flanked by a pair
of armed bodyguards it was plain from
the man's style of dress and demeanor
that he was both absurdly wealthy and
completely out of his mind he wore a
pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of
a Siberian tiger a pair of Dark Shades
with sequined rims obscured his eyes
from view but by far the strangest
aspect of the rich man was the fact that
emerging from the wrist of his right arm
was the eyeless head of Amore eel where
his hand should be the man spoke
addressing the entire room welcome
passengers new and old to the SS fateful
Emma while you're aboard this ship your
fate is in your own hands over the next
24 hours you will have the rare
opportunity to play the greatest game of
chance that Humanity has ever known
generations of people from every
continent and every Walk of Life have
given their all to the Mastery of rock
paper scissors across NOS blacks or
slashes the man proceeded to speak
unused usual syllables for the next
minute straight without even a pause for
breath in his report agent Zhang
described the man's voice as gaining an
increasingly loud hum as his speech
continued and that some of the syllables
didn't seem to be the product of human
vocal cords he soon concluded his string
of gibberish and resumed speaking
intelligible language as is customary we
will be utilizing the iljesh toei rules
you will Begin by selecting a single
opponent and challenging them to a best
of two of three match this is a single
elimination tournament and any
competitors who cannot otherwise
continue to engage in matches will also
be eliminated by the end of your time
here the luckiest among you will be
named the Undisputed champion of these
games and will be granted unlimited
Freedom along with the cash prize the
rest of you will have to determine your
own Fates where you all know what a way
to blow may your hands be ready your
minds be sharp and remember winning
is everything with a flourish of his
moray eel ham the wealthy man finished
his introductions and promptly exited
the room ajin Zhang looked at the
passengers surrounding him and saw that
they were already beginning to play Rock
Paper Scissors with each other a few had
already begun using the anomalous
gestures warping their limbs into
hideous subnautical shapes agent Zhang
gave the signal to agent DuBois and the
rest of the mobile task force to begin
the operation their target was primarily
the Moray handed man as well as any
other Close Associates that he had on
board they would capture him alive and
interrogate him into revealing the
mystery behind this illegal gambling
ring once the mercenaries were dealt
with agent Dubois team would further
command the ocean liner and navigate it
to SCP Foundation research site-45 to
await further orders as for agent Zhang
he knew what he had to do to buy time he
would participate in the ensuing rock
paper scissors tournament and eliminate
as many of the other players as possible
this he believed was the best way to
minimize the number of anomalous
gestures that would be used aboard the
ship of course he himself wouldn't be
using any of the anomalous gestures
either opting to limit himself to the
standard three this could put him at a
severe disadvantage over the course of
the competition but agent Zhang knew
better than to attempt fate still being
eliminated seemed like something he may
want to avoid even though the
consequences for elimination were left
vague in these strange rich man's speech
he still didn't feel that it would be
wise to put himself in a compromised
position while aboard the Fateful Emma
bracing himself for the worst agent
Chang accepted the challenge of a nearby
passenger he was off to a promising
start when he threw a scissors hand
against his opponent's paper because the
matches were best two out of three all
he needed was to win one of the next two
matches and he'd survive this round then
he saw the devious look on his
opponent's face and he knew that this
match was about to get weird rather than
admit defeat agent Zhang prepared to
throw scissors again the two challenged
their hands and just as Zhang had feared
his opponent threw an anomalous gesture
almost instantly the opponent's hand
took on a multi-mouthed piscene form
which began to spits sharp teeth in
agent Zhang's Direction fortunately the
agent's bulletproof vest was able to
withstand the impact of the teeth what
was even more fortunate was the fact
that the opponent seemed to be a good
sport scissors beats azravak U.N said
the other passenger before walking away
in search of their next match curiously
the passengers transformed arm continued
to fire teeth across the room at random
intervals occasionally hitting and
causing injury to one of the other
competitors agent Zhang was grateful
that the body armor he was wearing had
been tested to withstand rapid fire from
scp-127 compared to the raw power of the
living gun the teeth launched from
azerovoc gestures were practically DB
rounds he had succeeded in not being
eliminated both from the game and gen
excited about his win Zhang sought out
another opponent to test his lock below
deck agent DuBois and the rest of the
mobile task force had just finished
facing off against some of the hired
mercenaries when they entered a room
presumed to be the ocean liners sickbay
inside was a grisly sight a second rock
paper scissors tournament playing out
between players that had been so
thoroughly transformed by the anomalous
gestures of
scp-4633 that they barely appeared to
still be human it was like a scene from
a deep sea documentary with strange and
unknowable creatures vying for dominance
not within a natural food chain or
competition for resources but within a
seemingly never-ending struggle to win a
game of chance it was Purgatory rock
paper scissors Purgatory agent DuBois
was appalled but he knew better than to
attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all
distracted the moray-handed man was
still somewhere in the ship and
capturing him was far more important the
research team would decide what to do
with these former humans once the ship
was Secure within the foundation's
custody however what agent Dubois didn't
realize is that some of these creatures
were advancing on his team in
nightmarish and on Earthly voices they
chanted rock rock
paper scissors suddenly one of the
Abominations resembled nothing more
closely than an enormous mass of coral
produce Four Arms from within its body
and began to throw anomalous hand signs
towards the agents one of the arms threw
akyag which coded an unsuspecting agent
in hot lava causing him to drop to the
floor in pain Panic Dubois ordered the
task force to eliminate every living
thing in the sickbay although not in the
sense of their tournament standing of
course meanwhile ajin Zhang was on a win
streak in the function hall through
Sherlock and determination he had
managed to avoid elimination while
eliminating several other passengers
himself he began to notice that those
who were eliminated were quietly
escorted Away by the balance officers
seeming to have their anomalous changes
treated now it was only down to 12
remaining passengers agent Zhang knew
that it was only a matter of time before
DuBois and his team took control of the
ship but feeling Reckless he challenged
one of the remaining passengers in that
moment something came over him as if his
determination to see the mission through
was also compelling him to win at any
cost his opponent threw pagakumar and
out of instinct Zhang through vignanjak
the agent went on to win the entire
tournament but sadly he was unable to
collect the prize money as during the
Skirmish below deck the man with Amore
hand had escaped with a small fortune in
a high-speed submersible his ultimate
goals and the scope of the shadowy group
he represented would remain unanswered
for the time being when the SS fateful
Emma finally arrived at site 45 ajin
Zhang came to his senses and realized
that he had underestimated the cognitive
side effects of
scp-4633 due to the immediate
recognizable anomalous state of both his
arms ajin Zhang was later contained on
site with minimal security it's believed
that researchers are still searching for
a method to reverse the effects it just
goes to show that winning isn't
everything now go check out scp-439 bone
Hive and
scp-3989 the bone Orchard for more
terrifying Tales of body horror